hey man it's me kevin smith look at me
my funny goofy hat don't i look like
hella from thor
don't you sometimes just want to club
that kevin smith well how about instead
you joined that kevin smith club oh my
god we've been having such a good time
we have hours of audio kids in the
smodcast podcast archives that you can
stick into your ear holes and listen to
or do you want to look at something are
you one of them dirty cucks well then go
to the smithstoneian screening room
where you can watch hundreds of hours
of video of my entire career spanning
from the beginning up till now including
my daily morning show wake and bake man
will we just smoke weed hang out and i
tell you what i'm working on plus
there's exclusive events we've had
clerks three screenings for our club
members we've had smod castle exclusive
shows for our members back in jersey we
do events all the time including movies
pop-ups and there's tons of merchandise
of course that that kevin smith club
members get exclusive access to before
anybody else there are so many ways into
that kevin smith club ladies and
gentlemen you don't have to come through
the front door you can come through the
back door we like it that way sign up as
a clerk where you get access to all the
audio that we got or join as a mall rep
that gives you all the audio and all the
video as well or join as a fun employee
ladies and gentlemen you'll get a new
t-shirt an exclusive that kevin smith
club t-shirt
every quarter or join as a yoga hoser
and get yourself something cool like
that kevin smith waking bake bowl ladies
and gentlemen those are our existing
levels but what about the new levels
that's right for 2022 we've added some
levels including the fashionable mail
you get everything that the clerk the
mall rat the yoga hoser and the fun
employee gets but you also get once a
year an exclusive piece of wardrobe from
a kevin smith film straight out the
viewers universe from the secret stash
archives or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mall rep the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house i
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bacon it goes
up on spodcast man very exclusive once a
year we do that join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be a
mall rap be a fun employee be a yogas or
be a fashionable male be a ranger danger
or be a golden calf ladies and gentlemen
i'll be waking and baking for you come
join me at that kevin smith club
[Music]
all right
make some noise for kevin smith and mark
bernard
here comes fat man beyond
[Applause]
welcome back to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
here we all are kids back at the scum
and villainy cantina in hollywood right
on hollywood boulevard put your hands
together so the folks at home know
you're real man
so much to talk about but before we go a
quick story so today um i did uh today
was a big day for us historic day uh
kilroy was here dropped as the first
movie ever minted as an nft don't throw
a glass at me um
so in the morning i did a twitter spaces
for a couple hours uh that was great and
then afterwards
i had a photo shoot that i had to do
with jay for two different clothing
companies that we've been working with
last year we did what the kids these
days mark call like collab
with the hundreds that went very very
well they made some clothing centered
around the movies i've made
and the clothing you know small line bam
went out the door so two other companies
were doing that with at san diego
comic-con we launched a bunch of stuff
uh one is spirit um who we've done like
a movie shirt with in the past and now
we've done a bunch of stuff uh that's
coming out at comic-con and the other is
a company that i always assumed was
called results but as roosevelt really
and i kept that result
right like i'm not [__] i talked to
somebody in the real world i was like is
that a result shirt and they were like
yeah and they didn't correct me so i'm
like it is results but today when i went
to photograph with the people i was just
like i brought all my results stuff and
they're like but did you bring the
roosevelt stuff
and i was like that's what this [__]
company's called
i had no idea so two shoots the back to
back me and jay uh in outfits uh spirit
side and then roosevelt's side so first
uh half of it for me jay was there he
was doing a bunch of uh
photos before i even got there
my first set is with the spirit folks
and the spirit wear clothing is like so
[__] insanely comfortable it's like
loungewear he just
always feels like a big hooded
sweatshirt it's just wonderful [__] as
opposed to all the tight [__] you always
wear exactly that form-fitting [__]
you know lycra [__] i'm always in
so i love their [__] and i've worn it a
bunch particularly the movies one around
my house i also have a star wars one
that i got when i was at disney uh which
has like the action figures on it they
tend to
make clothing where they put puffy
letters on the back real huge and [__]
like that friend of mine ernie o'donnell
who runs smod castle like he's like look
like i always want to support your [__]
but if you got a shirt with like a
little thing on it here great he's like
this [__] is a [__] billboard man
like [__] i can't do it people love
it that particular style so we were
going in uh to do a fitting where i was
gonna put on everything and so the lady
from spirit was like you know start with
this outfit then there's this
movie's top and then all these and stuff
so
i put on the first outfit and it's like
a sweat outfit like you know sweatpants
say movie worlds movie world on them and
a hoodie zip down hoodie and they have
the look of like stonewashed jeans like
that's the kind of affectation to them i
get characters all over them put it on
i'm not really a sweat suitey kind of
guy so i got rid of the pants and just
put on my drawer i looked really good
next thing i took some pictures i i came
back in i put on this movie top
and said xl that's the biggest their
clothing is but it's a roomy xl
pull on this [__] xl movie top
and i look in the mirror i can't even
lower my arms i feel like a sausage
just a big purple [__] sausage and
for this outfit i'm also supposed to
wear not the backwards baseball cap that
i always wear but a what the kids call a
bucket hat
a purple bucket hat movies on it and
stuff so i'm already off the grid as far
as like what i normally look like and
[__] and in this top i'm feeling like
really sad i almost want to cry i'm like
my god i look so [__] fat and i wear
this all the time what happened i
thought i was losing weight and i went
back out and i was like hey like
do i get to kill any of these photos
before they see the public they're like
yeah is it good because i look like [__]
man i don't know if i want to be
photographed i'll let you take my
picture but like i think jay should be
the photo guy because look at me this is
ridiculous and [__] so i i went back in
we took pictures in that i was like i'll
put on the rest of them but no
guarantees i put on the next one roomies
[__] next one roomies [__] next one
roomies [__] i was like it was strange
as [__]
then there was another purple movies
thing that was on muse's side so i was
like oh maybe you know i got the wrong
one so i pull his it also says extra
large on it so both of these say extra
large but i'm like you know what i'm
[__] i this just even looks bigger so
i put on the other one fits perfectly
roomy as [__] so i go out to show the
people i'm like holy [__] man like i i
think
these two are two different sizes but
have excel tags in both of them i think
this is a large because like look how
you know how it fit you all saw and i
saw the horror in your eyes and [__]
i was like well this one this is the way
it's supposed to look and this is very
comfy and stuff so i mean maybe this one
just has the wrong tag in it maybe it's
a large with an xl sewn into it
they took it and then they looked at the
top tag and then there's a secondary tag
inside the guy opens it up he goes no
it's not a large
it's a
small and i was like what the [__] man
you don't do that to a man of my size
but then all of a sudden i was like
you know i didn't look my best but it's
good to know i could fit into a small if
i have to
so the day was saved right like if
batman needed you to wear a small you
could in an emergency like small has
been my kryptonite but now i'm like if i
have to
i don't want to but if i had we only got
a small space suit i can get into that
there's a thing that happened to me with
roosevelt and the spirit i got this
captain um that was my uh date uh today
and then of course coming here
uh tonight uh this week today is tuesday
tomorrow will be the one week
anniversary of the dropping of the
clerks iii trailer
yes
uh it played very [__] well i was so
delighted i was so scared the night
before it went out because i loved the
trailer so much and i thought like you
know like everything i do a bunch of
people would [__] on it and i was like i
don't know if i can handle that and
stuff
like this is so good i don't know if i
want people taking away my happy place
and so i obsessively watched the trailer
right before it went public for like
[__] one hour straight because i was
like it's gonna get ruined after this so
i might as well enjoy it and to my
surprise like the internet generally
embraced it you know it was either
positive to indifferent i was waiting
for a bunch of people to be like clerk's
three you should burn in hell three
times [__] prick but like
nothing really like that and and more
importantly you know we make these
things of course take out in the world
we're taking it out on the two different
ways it comes out through fathom events
screenings on september 13th and 15th we
just heard a report from them today that
they sold
more [__] tickets in advance than
they've ever sold before because we're
months out from the screening but since
the trailer went up and the tickets went
on sale they got a lot of pre-buys for
that and then the other way to see it is
with me on tour like we toured jane
salandbob reboot on clerks3 the
convenience tour you can go to clerk's
three-dot movie for all those dates and
[__] like that the tour dates are
[__] selling very well as well we
sold out in jersey and added another
[__] show uh same in seattle and
looks like a few of the others are about
to topple so so far
so good man and i'm just happy to report
that like if people like the trailer and
they seem to like the trailer
you will [__] love the movie because
it's the trailer times ten like that's
two minutes times it by ten
twenty minutes it is twenty minutes
of pretty solid movie
no what is 92 minutes so they've seen
two of 92 so times 45.
it's that trailer times 45 just sounds
like a kid making [__] up but it is it's
like the trailer truly encapsulates it
and uh and if you like the trailer my
god you're gonna vibe and uh vibe on and
love the movie but
relevant to our discussion here today uh
when folks saw the trailer did they see
anyone familiar
in the trailer
[Music]
[Applause]
mark didn't know he was going to be in
the trailer did you no
no because why would i think i'd be in
the [__] trail
i have no lines why do you put a dude
with no lines in a trailer i mean i play
silent bob bro like i'm in the trailer
too
what what uh what did you think when
you're watching the trailer and you're
like holy [__] he put me in there um a
why
because [__] it pays to know people
it pays to know people and i also
understood because i'm standing next to
michelle bouteau
who's hilarious
and like the day that i spent on the set
was just a day that i spent
next to her trying not to laugh
and so it was abundantly clear that
something of this was going to be in a
trailer somewhere um only because you
can't cut her out of everything if
anything and so like all right well
maybe he's in there with [__] nose i
don't know what's happening the trailer
is going to break the trend of broken
suddenly my mentions are like i saw you
clerks three bro there you go
good looking out and like what what the
[__] happened what did i do that's got
to be positive though compared to like
what you normally do with after the show
we're like shut up mark yeah better like
[__] mark come on you're ruining the
party marsh stop being so woke mark
yes it's all gonna be about race don't
it
speaking of race
[Applause]
step over here for a second
um for folks who are these deep cuts
[__] spoilers man maybe
some people you know don't want any of
clerk's three spoiled form and [__] so
if you don't you like cover yours or
whatever the [__] but
if you remember
years and years ago we made a very
unsuccessful clerks cartoon uh which
aired
thank you four people saw it which aired
twice on abc before they canceled it and
then all six episodes were put on uh
home video on like dvd and stuff like
that so
uh in
the clerk's cartoons
uh they would often go for advice from
time to time to their friend lando
mark is playing lando in clerks 3.
name checked as such name checked as
such and i wasn't supposed to be no like
because i was supposed to i was flying
into jersey just for this it's like i'm
flying [__] it i'ma shoot kevin's movie
it'll be great uh tell him what you were
gonna be doing i was gonna be he was
like hey can you just wear like jeans
and a t-shirt we're gonna have you
playing hockey on the roof of the quick
stop i was like
all right i hear that that's a sport
people play i don't know how you play it
because of all of the things about me
but all right yeah i'm happy to do it
and then don't act like it was a
culturally insensitive ask no it was
just a i could also fly a plane as much
as i know how to play hockey um
and then it was hey man uh could you uh
and it wasn't even you it was like
somebody else in the production who's
like uh this is all great could you come
in on tuesday
uh instead we're moving that scene to
tuesday and i said no
because i'm getting on a plane from la
to shoot a scene on saturday and then
get back on a plane on sunday to go back
to work on monday so i can't be here on
tuesday
and now they're like oh
okay give us a second and like three
days later
it's uh okay we figured something out
kevin's got a new idea it's going to be
even better we'll see you on saturday
because
and also it was hot as [__] balls
in new jersey in august yeah
particularly when we went on the roof
and shot that hockey scene it was 104
degrees that day yeah i tell you i was
the we got off the roof as fast as we
did we were only up there for like a
[__] hour they had blocked out six
hours to shoot on the roof and i was
like i know every beat i need because
the whole
opening sequence of the movie
is cut to uh my chemical romances
welcome to the black parade so i had
orchestrated and composed this [__] in
my head for years before we ever you
know [__] got the money to make
clerks three so by the time we hit the
deck
i was like oh i could i could [__] it
this is like driving mulholland i could
do it with my eyes closed you know
because i do it so often which don't
ever go with him
um so when i got up there i didn't need
all that time i just uh
basically shot exactly what i needed i
was like look i need like 14 beats for
the montage so give me two cameras
shooting game you guys do whatever you
want there's some key moments that i'll
try to tee up other than that
everything i get here is [__] golden
and it was hot everybody was [__]
sweating my friend vinnie pereira he
plays the goalie we named his character
hot goalie because he sweated [__]
balls the whole time and [__] like at
the hour mark i was able to be like
we're done production was like what the
[__] like we sent people home early that
day i'm the king of sending people home
early man
people love that like oh cause i know i
hate [__] like when you got a full
day scheduled and [__] and you're like
oh but then if all of a sudden something
cancels you're like [__] the time is
mine and [__] so like there we were with
like many hours to go and i was like
we're done kids i've got everything i
need go enjoy your [__] day the
hottest day in the world so you missed
the rooftop i missed the i saw them like
building the staircase to get to the top
of the roof and i was like oh
not for me
i'm good and so instead i got to hang
out for a day inside of a convenience
store with air conditioning with air
conditioning that's right and stepping
up as a character with a name i got a
name yeah
it wasn't just somebody somebody's dad
it was lando
king a [__] bespin it just proves
that it's all about who you know in the
business kids
how many salads you're willing to toss
to get in the mood
you've got dozer salad man it's a lot of
people are like oh he's all about
[__] nepotism and [__] because i put
my daughter in things
um nepotism carries across to all
members of the family so [__]
mark is also a victim of nepotism as
well
oh i wish they would stop this awful
that's just such abuse
uh what have you been up to man uh i've
been working man i'm coming to the end
of a gig on this friday um which has
been lovely and i'm sorry i still cannot
talk about it um
i could say this for him he can't it's a
high profile gig
um and then getting ready for [__]
comic-con man which is next week and i'm
ready to catch that cove that i'm gonna
get it do you think that's what's gonna
happen i mean
i haven't even thought about that
do you what i i go to i go to
conventions all the time like i just
came home from chicago fan expo i did
denver fan expo the week before and well
and i probably don't think about it
because i got coveted and now i'm like
licking doorknobs and [__] because
i'm [__] invincible but then they
said recently there's a new variant you
ain't invincible i'm like god [__]
damn it because i was just about to
start sucking dick unprotected
i'm about to raw dog some fans and i
don't care
up till now i've done it with the safety
of a prophylactic but now
i just want to go balls wild in my mouth
dental damn
um no well the way you do conventions
and normally do conventions is totally
different because you're the we bring
you through the back door and up to the
bowels of the convention center and like
there's a shield of people between you
and everything else and there's your
table you sit there and you sign things
and here's your picture booth you take
your pictures and then go back to your
hotel i got to walk that [__] floor
oh and that's
i mean all that all that humanity all
that humanity all of them probably
wearing masks i bet uh 100 bed i mean at
least
san diego has said whether do you have a
question
oh hey
it's a nice piece yeah anyway san diego
said now they have a
a vax policy where they're going to be
checking faxes at the door or negative
tests at the door
they've said there is or there yet there
is there is um i don't know how they're
feeling about masks or not but this
[__] is going to be triple
masked and double bagged the whole last
time
um
and doing my best to mitigate the amount
of time that i'm on the floor but you
know i got a couple panels on thursday
to do i got a podcast thursday night to
do
um i got some signings what podcast
you're doing thursday night yeah uh it's
a friend of mine um
phil
listen i went up to the edge of that
ramp and i have no lift i just let it
die and i just slowly rolled back down
the road
very adventure like evil knievel who's
like i'm not doing snake canyon today
and he just like backs the bike right up
that's where i went with that we've got
fat man beyond on thursday night indeed
we're also doing fat man beyond
updates yeah dailies i think as well um
i guess [__] i was going to say more
details next week but comic con is next
week well you'll get them bam i know hey
it's batman everybody give it up for j.c
i uh
i i can reveal i have details oh if we
want to share yeah please um so fat man
beyond is thursday night at 8 p.m
uh but it's sold out
and then we have
4 p.m on friday and saturday at movies
in the afternoon and that's
from what i understand if you go to
movies to eat during that time you just
kind of get a few shows
watch the show yeah that's happening and
stuff uh what are the times of the day
uh 8 p.m thursday and 4 p.m
the main show yeah and 4 p.m friday and
saturday saturday and we'll be streaming
all of it so if you can't get in you can
watch it at home just like this
or if you don't go to comic-con there
was one year where i was at comic-con
but it was so [__] crowded i couldn't
get to hall h and so i went to the hotel
and watched somebody streaming the hall
h panel and [__]
and i was like this will work
so yeah so i'm just preparing for that
i'm trying to psych up my immune system
to be a [__] rock star
um
and also just preparing my quarantine
for the week after
when i absolutely get it from to your
point the raw dog and all these
strangers
um it's going to be packed kids you can
find us at uh tin roof inn
in the gas light or gas lamp district
gas lamp gas lamp district um we're
taking over and turning it into a movies
pop-up for the entire time that's where
we're going to be doing our shows and
streaming and stuff i'm doing a [__] ton
of clerks three press while i'm there
probably going to be doing it there as
well
um
as jc mentioned a lot of it's sold out i
think even a lot of the reservations to
eat are sold out but we left some
walk-up spaces available
can i get something good yeah oh god
yeah yeah the talent gets anything they
want man you get free booze if you want
it i might never leave then
pull up a cot
what are you most looking forward to at
san diego i hear marvel as a panel i
hear that because theirs is right before
mine which is never a good sign
let's go get pizza everybody well what
happens is like historically marvel's
like marvel just [__]
[__] the [__] out of them till they
come and they're all exhausted i'm like
hey i'm back and like we're done and
they all [__] leave
hall h and [__] like that so i'm gonna
show the first five minutes of clerks
three but all they have to do is be like
you know here's look galactus everyone's
like
[Music]
so i guess it's good to follow them and
stuff it'd be better to be before them
it would be because people would want
seats take some solace in the knowledge
that they're saving some of their big
guns for d23 how do you know this uh
because they said so
um that comic-con like they will show
some stuff and one can probably guess
what they'll show can you guess what
would that be i i have no i'm no
imagination whatsoever my my big guess
is they will
what i was asking whoever [__] this is
bring that over here
um
for those who like i'm sure by now watch
at home if people put stuff on the bar
like we i'm happy to silent [__] mark
sign [__] what not uh but at a certain
point it strays all the way over there
and then i'm i'm out of the show and i
can't have
this that makes me feel relevant so
yeah pack it let me let me clear some
space for you here anyway back to you
sorry um but yeah if i had to guess and
it's purely a guess i think you might
get a look at black panther wakanda
forever is that right it's just a guess
but it's kind of next up on the [__]
cue
for them
what else is next for them besides that
ant-man 3
oh so we might see some of that no you
could see some of that you could see
some of uh the marvels
um you can see some tv [__] i know
they've been shooting um secret invasion
for a while you might get to see some of
that
um there's an iron heart show that may
or may not already be in production i
don't [__] know
i don't know anything
except for what i read on the internet
and then tell you sometimes poorly
um
but yeah and maybe they'll tell us what
phase four is
because i don't know what phase four is
do you guys know what phase four is
are we coming to the end of it i mean
theoretically but i also don't know what
the end of it would be because i don't
feel like we've been leading to a thing
um maybe it's a multiverse i don't know
maybe it's a war that secret who can
tell
but like we knew what the stones were
about like really early on
and how people keep talking about
[__] thanos is coming and i haven't
heard the name of anybody who's coming
that's true um
the the uh look i don't care i'm i'm not
like you know destination oriented i'm
just like a [__] dog in a car i'm
just happy to go for the ride
but yes there has been no event that
they seem to have been building up
toward but
i'm okay with that but i've seen two
think piece pieces this week
after i guess uh since thor came out of
people being like what the [__] was
phase four what is phase four did phase
four work or something like that i mean
financially it sure [__] did
i i wish i could be as much of a failure
as phase four
um
should we should we talk about thor um i
guess do we have any sponsor should we
do that first oh that's right we do have
i mean
listen apparently y'all are some olympic
[__]
because at some point
we will talk about blue chew again yeah
blue chew's back kids blue juice back
second half of the [__] show we were
talking about in the alleyway it's just
like what kind of old-ass fans do we
have
that are like i like to get my comic
book news from these guys and cure my
erectile dysfunction
uh but first up our first sponsor of the
first half of the show ladies and
gentlemen is uh
the good folks at native give it up for
native deodorant ladies and gentlemen
good folks at native and proud sponsors
of fat man beyond for a long time go to
what is it native native deo.com
fat man or use promo code fatman at
checkout for 20 off your first order
follow along there as we talk kids go
buy some native because they'll tell you
they make good product we ain't just
saying that because they like us and
stuff i i don't know how many different
ways to say this the bar for everything
in my life is whether my wife likes it
or not my wife lives for this native
[__] buys it outside of all of this
every once in a while they send us a
free sample or something like that
because we do the ads my wife buys this
[__] in bulk she loves it so much uh
what did they come up with copy for us
this week ooh would you like a dramatic
reading yeah oh all right let's see
give me morgan freeman
not because he's black just because he's
dramatic okay
after andy dufresne swam through four
miles of [__] he used native deodorant
it's pretty dramatic i was trying that
was good i was trying uh all right you
get lines in the next movie after that
who else can you do
nobody well
uh you've heard kevin talk about how
much he loves native deodorant the
thoughtful formulation behind all their
products i'm not doing it with what
did they really write that into the well
no that's that oh you put my name in i
put your name in
i was so excited i was like they know me
man
i wanted you to have the smile of a kid
at disneyland who's never seen his name
on the license plate rack and then
there's your [__] name oh my god it's
like you know what shaniqua they heard
your [__] plea it's like now you get
a license like you were there for my
childhood
were there not enough kevin's then i
doubled down on that [__] when i named
my kid harley and spent her whole life
looking for her name anywhere other than
obnoxious biker clothing and [__]
which would really show off parts of the
kid i didn't want to but i would always
look for a little license plates at
harley haley everywhere there's a hallie
i remember asking the toys r us once
before they closed god rest their
[__] souls i was like you can't
afford a [__] r they're like no it's
in the sign backwards
i would like you to have taken her to
sturgis just once for the harley rally
my name is everywhere it's everywhere so
yes uh native because they understand
it's not just on the outside that counts
but also what's on the inside that's why
native is releasing their deodorant that
he knows and loves i'm a fan too in new
and improved plastic free packaging
they're doing their part to help our
earth with their new 100 plastic free
and recyclable packaging and when you
buy natives new plastic free recycled
package deodorant you are saving 37
grams of plastic what happens to those
37 grams they have not been clear with
uh native is also a proud partner of one
percent for the planet and are
committing 100 of their plastic free
deodorant sales to environmental
nonprofits
and listen i i have not been as as
ardent as a supporter of native as i
probably could be
um i'm glad you're finally [__]
admitting i'm inviting all these people
i'm coming out and saying it but
they sent me this [__] vanilla
cupcake body wash
didn't you want to eat yourself
afterwards no
i spent like teenager time in the shower
like just [__] like what's happening
to me why do i smell like a pillsbury
doughboy this is amazing you all right
in there fine mom
nothing to see here it's just me rubbing
myself with batter in the shower truly
if you want your dick to taste like
cookies native is for you
i believe that's their new slogan yeah
oh they wrote it right here yes right in
the copy
i'm telling you they make [__] that you
want to eat and it's vegan so you might
be able to hell yeah so if you're ready
to try plastic free deodorant or smell
like a cupcake everywhere you go go to
nativedeo.com fat man or use the promo
code fat mana check out and get 20 off
your first order
boom
we love the good folks at native give it
up for native kids
we thank the fine folks day of deodorant
for sponsoring uh the first half of
tonight's fat man beyond uh see what i'm
holding here is uh choger and my friend
the artist made this uh view guru askew
and he made two other versions one was
red one was green this is the black and
white version isn't it [__] adorable
children where can they get that
sideshow collectibles.com but if you're
like look i don't give a [__] about
kevin smith all i love is jay and silent
bob those [__] irr irrepressible maul
rats well chogrin did us literally as
mall rats
so there's a j there's a sound bob maul
rats they get them at the same place
where which one is this
so if you want the mall rats you go to
uvdtoys.com isn't that [__] gorgeous
and clever why did it take 25 years for
somebody to be like let me do you as
rats
it takes a brilliant mind man chogrin's
got that mind um okay shall we talk
about
the things that we've seen we got not a
lot of news but many reviews so we've
seen a lot of [__] someone put a note
and said these are for me who gave me
these
whoo you it's [__] phenomenal man
there's a pack of [__] genuine actual
wax pack of batman 1989 batman cars i'm
gonna eat this gun when i get home you
got the red but you got the second
series [__] oh we can trade i'll be
like got it needed got it
god this gives me so much joy man i saw
this this took me right back to like
some happy times going as a five and
dime store in my hometown called sink or
swim they had all the [__] the the
cards the packs and stuff like that used
to be like uh get wacky packs of 25 this
says six dollars what the [__]
is that like what they charge in the
modern world
that's expensive how much is yours
same thing or is it because it's second
series lower
45 dollars who i got the night what the
[__]
[Applause]
this is [__] thoughtful as [__]
thanks man i'm gonna enjoy i literally
i'm gonna open them up when i go home
take a [__] tonight i'm gonna open them
up and look at each one
you know you could get some toilet paper
though
i will use that but
sorry joker bath
bathroom is very precious space for me
so if i take him in there it's an honor
my friend
um okay let's review things yes uh now
and when we say review we don't mean
like you know [__] thumbs up thumbs
down we mean review like a show we're
going to put on a show
dancing
yes there will be dancing some of one of
us is going to dance around things
the other of us is going to tell you how
much he hated [__]
you may continue counseling
but watch your step let's start with the
boys
the boys
another excellent season [__] kripke
man fast becoming one of my favorite
writers out there him and all of his
crew uh great story line this year
care about these characters still
they have somehow find a way to make you
[__] despise
homelander yet not want him to be killed
because you're like [__] what happens if
he goes away you want him dead
no one more season one more season one
more season get him and emmy um he's i
mean that's the thing what a [__]
lead they found in him he's absolutely
tremendous and carries up he's like i
mean it's an old reference kids but
remember marco remember remember like
[__] in the 70s in the 80s everyone
was like oh jr ewing you love to hate
j.r on dallas he's like [__] the
modern day version of that just you know
entertaining and very very larry hagman
yeah charming as [__]
um now we're making jokes just for our
moms
uh i love the entire season uh i i was i
did not know that the recent episode was
gonna be the finale but they started
tying up threads [__] left and right
and i looked at the length and i was
like holy [__] i think they're bringing
this bird in for a landing and i think
they did so well uh terrifying
showing this the
the kind of casual acceptance
of homelanders
public mask slipping
which we saw a few times earlier in the
season um he was delighted to find out
that his numbers went up when he [__]
spoke his mind so to speak a segment of
the population went for it but in the
last episode spoilers there's a moment
where
he goes [__] full homelander in front
of everybody
and rather than you know everybody
[__] run away
they one guy starts clapping others
start clapping you get the impression
that next season is going to be about
how
far can i go how far
can i push like and will they still love
me
it's not to mention what he's doing with
his kid too they they have not been
particularly coy
about the homelander donald
w whatever his middle name is trump
analogies and to the point where the
finale is literally i could shoot a guy
on fifth avenue and nobody would care
yeah and it's i could blow a dude's head
away with my eyes and people would
applaud
and it it did tickle me as i'm sure and
it clearly tickled eric cripty to
discover that there was a vast swath of
an audience who was watching this show
rooting for homelander not getting the
joke
like oh oh
oh wait are you talking about us
yeah man you gotta remember like uh all
in the family ran for years and people
loved archie bunker even the people at
archie bunker was portraying yeah they
thought he was speaking for them and
stuff sometimes your satire could be so
good
it's uh people forget that satire just
take it as truth
um i i similarly i loved the third
season i think was the strongest season
to date
um the one thing that huey continues to
be adorable as does star girl
i ship the starlight i ship the sorry dc
and [__] disney plus they also have a
show called star girl they have a movie
called is that what it is and a show
called star girl is on the cw and then
starlight starlight a lot of stars she
gave up the costume does that mean she
gives up the name as well you think
um i don't know i don't know maybe she's
gonna team to turn that [__] at this
point this name is hers
and not ikes
i i like that see yeah
um my one quibble
was
i was hoping that they would do
something else with homelander only
because we seem to end every season with
we're about to [__] up homelander and
then homelanders just re re-energized
and renewed with his level of indecency
and awfulness to the point where next
season will also be how are we gonna
[__] take on homelander like this was
the version of the show to have done
that
and i'm personally a little bit more
intrigued by what a homeland without
powers is
what a whole lot because they seem to
have been like i miss this part in the
show where we're taking people's powers
away that was soldier boy's whole jam
was like he would have this [__]
explodey [__] and then people's powers
would would vanish right
and like do that what is what does your
evil god look like when he can no longer
do god [__]
and what does it look like when that
dude is angry and has a son who loves
him
like it just it felt like it was a more
interesting way to take that character
and to twist it so that next season is
not again just how do we take down
superman it's what the [__] does that
guy do now that he's desperate he's
never been desperate before did you
think when spoilers again did you think
when him and maeve were fighting and she
[__]
like dug the spine and the the spike
into his ear
like oh my god [__] something bad's
gonna happen and nothing bad happened
yeah like i just i want i want there to
be some evolution to the homelander
story aside from just kind of more of
the same
um i like maeve's storyline this year
for that reason her whole arc was good
and
the way she went out
was great and then the ps
was even more satisfying which oddly
enough i still didn't see coming i'm
such a rude man you could trick me so
easily
with [__] anything i still get like
what do you mean
rudolph's nose what red like you know
so easy to get me and i they got me on
that i didn't see that coming at all
um but yeah i mean
that [__] show that writing staff
those actors the noir story oh so
[__] great man and so bittersweet so
sad and uh and [__] tragic but also
entertaining as [__] when he goes into
like the close fast food joint and all
the cartoon characters talking to them
like come on irving
[Laughter]
oh it was adorable um and then they i
thought it was really [__] uh
harrowing how like he'd be surrounded by
these cartoons and then they would just
cut to the real world of him sitting
alone in a room that's all quiet
some good [__] yeah and i'm i'm
continuously impressed by the way they
managed to make characters who felt like
they were one note and continue to
develop them and double down on them
like i i thought that there was no more
a train story to tell
until
he's now
now he's in a denzel washington bob
hoskins movie from 1983.
holy [__] i forgot about that flick
where he wakes up with a racist heart
yes
a racist heart
like
that's pretty great and there was legit
a [__] denzel washington movie called
critical condition i think is the name
of the movie i think you're right where
uh yeah i think it's bob hoskins there's
a no george siegel is the one where he's
his dad that's carbon copy carbon copy
but i think it's bob hoskins called
condition where hoskins is an awful
[__] dude who like
has a heart condition or whatever and
denzel dies young and they're like we
can only save you here's the heart that
showed up
and then it's like
i don't want that hot don't give me it
don't give it a hug you gotta put me in
that body and of course now bob hoskins
is still in the movie as like the voice
of the heart who's talking [__] to
denzel the whole time until they
literally have
changes of heart
you committed that movie to memory far
more than i did
just remember the trailer and that's
about it
it's one of those like did they really
make that [__] movie
like same thing with soul man when
you're like they made this movie right
yeah
i remember when they made that movie
even then i was like are you sure you're
allowed to do that yeah and then like
james earl jones is in that movie
as like
james earl [__] jones
you're like did you not read the script
james
oh you had a house payment all right i
get it [__] he was like i find your
lack of faith disturbing me
also doom got to eat but still
um so no i'm i'm 100 on borough for the
boys i will watch whatever those guys do
um i was just hoping amazon killing it
with their
comic book programming their superhero
stuff
between the boys and invincible
and then um
there's something else they said they
were adding i saw recently
i forget what it is but they're going in
with another comic book project which i
was happy to see
maybe that's maybe they're going to be
the new cw
somebody needs to be yeah really old cw
seems to be giving up
um
have are you caught up on ms marvel i am
what a [__] phenomenal show
so magical literally so [__] magical
and interesting as [__]
look i i you know
blame me or blame the american
educational system but i didn't [__]
know the history of the partition yeah
you know it's like i remember some stuff
from gandhi
but like when [__] went south after
gandhi died but like that was
fascinating history to me that like you
don't have to show me
superheroes beating the [__] out of each
other if you show me a compelling human
[__] drama it was a really moving
story i you know i if somebody had asked
me in the beginning like
uh hey man they're gonna go to karachi
at one point i'd be like what does that
have to do with the marvel universe and
apparently [__] everything and not
just that but it was like what a great
look into like a world that i'm not
familiar with it was just really really
interesting we had the one guy here a
couple weeks ago who was like i was just
happy to watch a show where their house
was decorated like the house i grew up
in
um
yeah it's been such a great watch that
girl continues to be
just dazzling
the mom
lady who plays her mom
is [__] phenomenal um the whole cast
is really really great but the storyline
i thought was incredibly
[__] moving with the grandmother and
the mother and the and the granddaughter
and
you know crossing the time stream and
the conundrum of you know
being the person who
connects the past and somehow
you are the president is all well told
and continues to be insanely well shot
one of the best looking shows on tv yeah
i think they benefit very greatly from
at least for that chunk of it i'm not
sure where they shot the rest of the
show
but they did not shoot the karachi stuff
in atlanta
no or or jersey city [__] is atlanta
yeah that i 100 by but like that stuff
as i understand they went to thailand
because going to pakistan or karachi is
a little bit dodgy politically and all
that stuff so they went to thailand and
then recreated
all of that stuff like to the letter by
the looks of it wow and it's it has the
feel of a place that's not here which
it's hard to do anymore in these marvel
shows which always kind of feel like
a bit of atlanta
in terms of how they shoot in terms of
yeah like how they kind of feel and like
moon knight to their credit they did go
overseas and they did kind of bounce
around a bit and it did betray that
level of international ambition but
like loki felt like it was on a set the
whole time yeah because it probably was
they were shooting during covid and like
that's how you'd pull that off but this
it had a feel that was different and
unique to itself and and yeah i think
you know the partition stuff is so
captivating and i think this show is
doing for partition what watchmen did
for tulsa 21 agreed absolutely let's
teach we were going to educate the world
on something that a bunch of people knew
about but a bunch of other people more
way more people didn't like this
happened yeah it was this bad worse oh
[__] maybe i should like read up about
it
and so do that
excellent pro tip right there
um what a wonderful series man is it now
that obi-wan kenobi is is kind of over
is being paid to it has its ratings gone
up or views gone up um i'm not sure i'm
not sure it deserves like if it felt
like i think we talked about it that
obi-wan might have overshadowed it
because they started them the same time
but now that obi-wan is done it felt
like this was their time to
shine for people to catch you up be like
oh i haven't watched these yet because
it's a delightful show it very much
reminds me of spider-man the same way
that what's the guy who makes spider-man
uh john watts same way john watts
handles and the writers handle
spider-man with the all the vitality of
youth like it just makes you want to be
young again you watch that show and
you're like [__] being a teen was cool
wasn't it
so they're doing something great with
that stuff i hope more people start
watching it um they're missing out by
not seriously yeah and i hope that when
the marvel's movie comes out of which
iman vinali valani will be playing
kamala khan so maybe they'll
retroactively go maybe they'll go back
like oh where does that girl come from
oh this is really
good one can only open one um
all right do stranger things kids uh
full disclosure i've never watched
stranger things
we've talked about it before uh we
almost did this week my wife was like
this could be the week we start stranger
things
and instead we've taken to our new past
time which is on youtube public freakout
videos
oh my god people are so hostile out
there
and it's delicious to watch man
like we just sit there at night and [__]
i watch these hour-long compilations of
these public meltdowns with all these
cairns man i gotta tell you it's just a
sea of [__] [__] white people man
like
and none of them are justified is that a
single one me and my wife look at each
other throughout all of them going like
just walk away like why would you do
this either that or [__] you know
airline videos that's that's been my new
[__] go-to so stranger things we'll
have to wait but mark watched strange
things i finished stranger things i will
say this i watched the one clip where
they did master of puppets which was one
of the most metal [__] things i've
ever seen in my life it doesn't
shredding the opening
it was like but then someone had a
public freak out and i had to watch that
instead yeah what can we do that'll feel
like the side of a van oh i know
master of puppets with
bat demons and red lightning in the
background i got to imagine
you know
based on that clip alone that i watched
with master of puppets
like
and we all know
how you know metallica
can be about their material and stuff
i guess they got a lot of money to make
that stranger things show
they they got a buck or two over there
huh
they uh they they spare no expense when
they don't want to spare an expense
because
they're the biggest show that netflix
has ever had
and so when they want to [__] how
much will it cost we'll pay it
double it just for just for kicks
this is how culturally
like unaware i am at this particular
moment in time when it comes to stranger
things i was talking to somebody and um
i was like they're like what are you
working on i was like oh i'm writing
this thing that's like set in 1986 i
want to do an 80s thing i said there's
not enough 80s things as far as i'm
concerned
and they're like [__] stranger things
i'm like that's set in the 80s
is it it is yeah
another reason i should be watching this
[__] show man i mean i gotta get to
it like in the second season the kids
dress up as ghostbusters for halloween
oh my god
yeah
it's all that
all right
bam
bam is here don't you rub it in uh no
i'm gonna defend you oh there if it's
like if the thing is is like they love
star wars and metallica and
and ghostbusters like it could be 2020.
it's true
good point man yeah um i i won't go too
deep into it because you haven't seen it
so it would be a little bit of a waste
but i will say
that they they they landed the plane
that they wanted to land landed why it's
not over is it this was the season
finale oh but they've they're got a
fifth season coming which they [__]
keyed up incredibly well at the end of
the season
i still love all of these kids even
though almost none of them look like
they're in high school anymore
i think that they have so many
characters to juggle and the fact that
they are able to do any of that is
somewhat miraculous
even though from the finale
which was two and a half hours long it's
like guys that could have been two
episodes and i'd have been having it
could have been three episodes would
have been fine why did they put it into
uh two
or into one movie did they ever say just
because they wanted to have the feel of
one moment i think so
and to their credit it never lags it
always moves like you're never like this
is too long even though you are feeling
it's a bit too long but [__] is
happening all the time but they have to
jump like star wars style between five
different stories to the point where you
forget what any of these stories have to
do with the main narrative it's like oh
what the russia stuff is also have to do
with the hawkins stuff which also has to
do with the upside down stuff and how
does that work i don't remember i'll
just kill the demon dog excellent all
right cool that was neat
it's like oh the helicopter flew that's
cool
um
there's there is there's a death that
i'm not sure is a death
um because in fantasy nobody dies
until you see the [__] funeral and
even then you can't be certain
um
but yeah i thought it it was emotional
in all the ways needed to be emotional
it was epic in all the ways and needed
to be epic and it's teeing up a fifth
season which does seem to change the
paradigm for what the show is um so i'm
i'm 100 on board
sorry it's all right
um all right stranger things done
stranger things done i can re-engage
with the show um have you seen
have you seen star trek strange new
worlds no but you could talk about it
disengage
um
it's [__] awesome i know you continue
to like it
is this a good entry point for somebody
who hasn't watched the last nine star
wars show star trek shows yes if all
you've ever seen is the original series
or the movies or the movies this is the
perfect entry point for you is it really
because you know all you need to know i
like that lead man
yeah he's a nice dude and he's a real
good actor with the johnny bravo hair
yes because that hair is [__] serious
altitude but it's
it is just fun like it's fun and it's
it's light and it's breezy until it
decides to like drop anchor and dip into
real human emotion about [__] fake
people in a fake future is this a
paramount plush show it is a paramount
plus show you're gonna have to invest
and or do a trial and then drop it in a
week after you finish binging and
[__] strange new worlds i'm not gonna
tell you how to save your money but i
already have it i got that app i get all
the apps i really write them off you
know cause it's like it's i'm in the
business so i'm like i just write them
all off but i got them all and [__] so
if you ever want to come over and watch
acorn
do you have a brit box why yes i do yes
i do i'm subscribed to everything man
amc plus sure
still trying to make that dc universe
app work won't happen
you can read some comics though yeah
that's true
uh all right should we talk about it
that's the last thing to talk about is
uh thor love and thunder yes how many
people saw thor loving thunder
just tonight uh uh if you didn't you're
[__] out of luck because we're about to
[__] this movie up for you yeah
uh just out of curiosity put your hands
together how many people didn't see uh
thor love and
thunder it's a smattering of people uh
do you have intentions of seeing it or
you're just like that ain't for me
you are going to see it well you're
going to hear about it first
just
your way through the next 10 minutes uh
full disclosure i feel like i have to do
this before i talk about any movie uh
i'm a director uh sometimes and um
uh i fully admit that uh the the the
filmmakers that we talk about on the
show all the time uh can make way better
movies uh than me i could never make a
decent thor movie let alone a good thor
movie let alone a fun thor movie so uh
take it all uh with a grain of salt
after that ladies and gentlemen uh that
being said i enjoyed it i did i love it
as much as thor ragnarok
uh thor ragnarok was an absolute [__]
discovery you know and something i was
not expecting i went into thor love and
thunder with a certain amount of
expectation based on of course what i
was given before and i got exactly the
you know
what i thought i would get coming uh but
of course the element of surprise
isn't quite there like it was last time
um
that being said a [__] devastatingly
entertaining
marvel movie uh uh adorable fun the only
things i bumped into story-wise were
um
i you know the guardians were gone so
fast i didn't even know why they needed
to be there other than he left
one movie with them
and then showed up in this movie with
him then suddenly they were gone peter
quill looks [__] thin man did you
notice that [__] yeah he was he was the
only thing i got out of the whole garden
sequence is like give that [__] a
sandwich man
what happened to him bucky looks scrawny
um and then my the other thing i bumped
into in the is the
main plot like uh thor the god butcher
which is a big one a big one yeah you
know what it is
uh you got thor the god butcher and he's
there to butcher some gods yeah there's
your movie right i mean and thor is a
god yeah conflict
so you got a movie um all of a sudden in
the third act he's like no man i'm gonna
get to eternity and make a wish and then
i gotta capture kids as well and it just
seemed like hat on a hat on a hat it's
like just stick to killing gods that's
bad enough right and so the other thing
in into eternity and one night just felt
like
well
okay well what happened to just killing
all the gods because he's got the cool
last sword suddenly the cool ass sword
wasn't enough
he needed a [__]
storm storm breaker bring
um i thought all that [__] was wonderful
the [__] you know jealousy with
[__] stormbreaker coming into frame
and [__] and just mean mugging him him
looking after his hammer and whatnot uh
story of a man and his tools
um but uh yeah i just didn't i i i
didn't think they needed to go
to eternity i thought you know them
fighting in uh black and white thor
clerks world i thought was cool enough
yeah that was amazing i thought so too i
was like so that's what black and white
looks like now
yeah and like if you're gonna go to
eternity
then
why doesn't thor or jane get a wish
like
why doesn't the why does the bad guy get
to have a final wish granted i'll be
honest with you i'm glad they didn't
cause that would have been the easy out
for the jane storyline unless she makes
the different choice than you think
she's going to make
unless you think she's going to say i
want my life back curing me this cancer
but instead she says
whatever the [__] maybe it is i do want
to give gor the god butcher his daughter
back maybe my life is done but a new
life should be able to begin maybe maybe
it's [__] john wick maybe it's thor
you shouldn't be alone anymore and i'm
going to give you this gift which is a
new life for you to take care of and
guard as you would have cared for mine
then it's a [__] then it's a story
about your heroes as opposed to a story
about gore the god butcher who doesn't
need like i'm i'm a little
perplexed by this new desire to redeem
bad guys like just be a [__] bad guy
that seems to be the thing over there
they want to humanize their bad guys a
lot or redeem them yeah
um i agree sometimes just you know he's
a god bless you let him put your gods
until you before and he was just of like
i like the backstory and as much as like
all right now we get it why is god
butchering stuff but
i guess if he doesn't get redemption at
the end we don't have a title for the
[__] movie
you know or if he doesn't get redemption
at the end christian bale does not sign
on to be your god butcher do you think
that's it you think he's like i'm not
going to be an irredeemable bad guy it
would not support he played american
psycho
yeah been there done that yeah i now
have like i've got children some of
which who were young as guardians like i
did pay attention to the credits he had
kids there too how many hemsworths
nytd's and bales were children
in that scene oh i think nepotism is
[__] disgusting
no place for it
[Applause]
i thought that was adorable when i read
that it was hemsworth's kid
spoilers again lots of spoilers amazon's
kid playing the you know the little
god god butcher's [__] daughter
um and hence the you know uh love at the
end
absolutely [__] adorable like i
thought that was really sweet um
christian bale once again proving what a
[__] maestro
an actor is
taking a like what could have been a
thankless role
and bringing a voice to it not just an
accent but bringing true [__]
creepiness like there were moments when
he was doing his thing
with the kids where i was like this is
true he's unnerving like it's not just
your typical like oh he's bad guy
because he's got a cape he just sounded
[__] psychotic and [__] like that i
loved his performance um valkyrie great
as usual but seemed
like didn't she didn't have a bunch to
do
no i mean i did i wanted her to have
more to do
i well i i saw the movie twice i saw it
once did you i did i did i saw it once
opening night thursday night and went
with the [__] nerds and and rolled
out to go see it you saw we were
supposed to watch it together
screenx our good friend brett deacon who
works at 4dx and screenx he held a
screening for us uh and mark couldn't go
during the day but he wound up going at
night i saw it in screenx so i had the
[__] walls surrounding me yeah it was
[__] gorgeous beautiful presentation
and i saw it again today this morning
the [__] i did i went twice because i
wanted to like i like to get to see a
movie twice before we talk about it
because there's your emotional reaction
to it and then there's your all right
well what is this movie anyway what's it
trying to do is that why i'm always like
oh i loved it
[Applause]
because i don't take the second
discerning screening to be like did i
love it how do i feel
and i just kept on feeling that all of
these valkyrie scenes seem like they're
valkyrie scenes because you want to have
tessa thompson in your movie
when they feel like they want it to be
sift scenes
because she was in it she's in it for
like two scenes once she loses an arm
the other time she's doing [__]
one-armed sword play with a child and
i'm like but this is the woman who
actually has a relationship with thor
this is a woman who was in love with
thor like deep abiding unrequited love
with thor
so put her on that [__] [__] like
have her need to be there for the guy
that she loves but is still her deepest
friend and counsel him through his
[__] romantic nonsense
like
that's good that's bittersweet where
she's gotta help him
be with her you know and then like let
her do some badass one-armed
battle [__] she's lady sith for christ's
sake like let her do some [__] but or
you know don't cut her arm off or don't
cut her arm off or she's also a god and
valkyrie isn't so for her to go on this
mission is risking her own life in a way
that valkyrie like she should be king of
new asgard that's her job and i get that
she's like i want to go off and fight i
want to go off and hack some [__] to
bits and the little like kind of
friendship story between her and jane is
nice but
this if it's if it's a thor movie
then you kind of want all of the
characters to be functioning and and
attacking tucking towards thor himself
and valkyrie doesn't really do that but
sif does you know and and the further i
got into the movie like i liked the
first 30 minutes of it because it's
when [__] thor is kicking the [__]
out of the owls yeah when he's van
damming his way through the [__]
fights yes
that's just inspired [__] and soundtrack
phenomenal i mean heavy guns and roses
yeah which i'm here for i kind of wish
though that like somebody like queen
could have done the score
you know like
[__] get me rage against the machine
to do an entire wall-to-wall soundtrack
for a thor movie like queen's queen did
for
flash gordon so it's not just these
needle drops of guns and roses but it's
just [__] orchestral rock and roll
um but anyway like the first half an
hour is really fun because it's a guy
who's not engaging with himself and i
get it so it's all very jokey and laffy
and whatever
but it doesn't ride the tone that you
kind of wanted to because it can never
be serious because it seems like they
always want to be making a joke right
and it wants to be serious like look the
last one
didn't want to be really serious at all
and yet there was one of the most
touching personal moments in a thor
movie
when the two are in the elevator and
he's like loki i thought the world of
you and he has that little conversation
with him and you're like where the [__]
did this
lump in my throat come from i i thought
i was having fun
and so they could you know it was a fun
movie that they periodically infused
with just the right amounts of drama
here once you start dealing with a
storyline that involves cancer it's like
tough to be jokey all the way through
like i think ragnarok the genius of
ragnarok is that it's a funny movie in
which your lead character is not in on
the joke
but in this movie thor is very much part
of this actually that's pretty good you
know like he's very like i'm going to
have all of this [__] sexual tension
with these inanimate objects that
clearly i probably have sex with once or
twice because it's lonely in space
all of that is like oh it's funny i get
it but thor is now trying to be funny
on the one side of the hammer it says um
you know whoever lifts this hammer on
the other side says whoever takes this
hammer
be you worthy yes um so it just it
always like it it didn't find a way to
be melodramatic the way you want a
superhero movie to be especially when
it's about cancer and it's about choice
and it's about who do i get to be as a
hero or a heroine because the last half
of that movie feels like it's a jane
movie it feels like it's a
i'm the character who's making the
heroic choice at the end of it i'm the
one who decides to sacrifice my life to
save these children and save the
universe
not thor it sounds like remember you
were like well that's how you get
christian bale
sounds like that's how you get natalie
portman yeah and so but then the movie's
somewhat imbalanced because
she's also weirdly joking and not great
at that part but she's trying to be
funny in a movie that's asking her to be
funny but she wants to be serious
because about cancer it's just it's it
gets him balanced in ways that that
start to tip it
off the axis it wants to be on
all of that said works
i i charm city i had a really good time
watching a movie i didn't like that much
what a great review put that on a poster
barb
um is it because of him for me it's him
it's like the movie rises and falls on
him and he's charm city chris hemsworth
you know he's great absolutely adorable
and i think there's especially that
moment at the very end and it reminded
me a little bit of buffy it reminded me
a little bit of you know the harry
potter but the
every kid gets to be a hero today
you know loved it like it's absolutely
suddenly like like i've got a lump in
mind he was just like you know for a
limited time
really [__] great that was wonderful
and it's great and watching all those
kids [__] kick ass and then november
rain kicks in and like all the things
you want to happen happen and it doesn't
matter that that's probably not how
thor's powers work like who gives a [__]
like right because it's emotional it
works and you ride with it but then
there are times when you're like okay so
how does this lightning bolt thing work
and
zeus
okay
boy he was having a good time he was
having like twice as much of a good time
than the movie needed him to happen
like oh i could take this much [__]
zeus
and i kept on wondering so zeus is the
oldest of the gods
not raw maybe not
you know best perhaps they had a chance
to bring in konshu i was happy to see
they showed a few of the what are the uh
eternals uh
yeah the the
the celestials yeah like at one point
you saw two celestials i was like dope
but it's the bar is real low for me man
it's real low i was like i saw a thing
but i kept on like so how many black
gods we got here in this city of a guy
i don't know homie given that that's
where
life started but sure zeus king of the
gods why not
doing that accent which was like cute
for a little bit and then you're like
when he's doing the greek accent yeah
like i don't know what you're talking
about the thor like oh
throttle back homie
there might be actual greeks who see
this movie and are not pleased i was i
was thinking that i was like is he does
he have any greek in his background like
are you allowed to do that
i i don't know
but then again it to me a mario is a
thing
i don't know how many oh my god that's
kind of what his performance sounded
like a little bit
a little bit um i will say though
the goats were hysterical the go every
time the goat showed up i was like
just all that [__] screaming was
delicious and i will not spoil the first
of the post-credit sequences except to
say that when the first one happened i
clapped like a [__] child in the
theater
when you meet yes
yes
he's here he's there he's every [__]
where yeah
that was amazing and also
looked like the marvel version 100 yeah
it's like
yeah
that was the first thing i was like holy
[__] and then i realized who it was and
i was like holy [__]
yeah that was great man you know you've
made it when [__]
they put you as the [__] post-credits
scene in a marvel movie yeah he's
beloved at this point the second
post-credit sequence which again is
going to be tough to talk about without
spoiling but
i actually thought was kind of this was
my read on it i thought it was kind of
touching so in the post-credit the
second post credit sequence one of our
characters i mean everybody
somebody goes to valhalla
yes
but historically speaking
you only go to valhalla if you die in
battle gloriously in battle correct
but this character going to valhalla was
a real statement
a real like emotional touching statement
to me about
the battle that that person went through
like
there's the battlefield
and then there's the battle of terminal
illness right and i thought that was so
beautiful i don't know if that was their
intention but that is what i walked away
with from that scene
um
you get that at all um i didn't but now
that you say it
doesn't work though it works that way
for me although i kept
and and maybe this will have been the
case anyway maybe they just cut the
frame a little bit short but
i wanted that character to deny intrigue
to herself
sorry i heard i i heard there was a
version where she did
i read online i mean i don't know if the
people who said it online no [__] but
i saw a thing that said there was a
version where
she didn't or whatever yeah because like
that's
i wanted more for that character and
from that character going forward and
the idea that she would
we keep dodging around it even though we
keep giving it away um
and everyone's like we know who you're
talking right but we'll still pretend
but you know that she would turn her
back on eternity for a chance to go back
to thor
felt
that felt like that's where the story
was leading to was the i would do
anything for one more day i would do i
would give up anything to be with you
again unless i have to save the world
and save your life in which case mine
will be forfeit and that's fine but if
given the choice
like i don't need a mead hall and i
don't need [__] rousing songs about
viking glory
if i can have another day with that guy
and so to not kind of
not to button that the way you kind of
hoped that you could get that button
you know it would be the mirror of that
the post-credits scene of thor the dark
world in which jane is waiting for
[__] thor to show up in days and
weeks and whatever go by and then she
hears the [__] bifrost open outside
and then he's back like have [__]
thor have be sad and disturbed and
whatever and he's got his adopted
daughter
nephew niece whatever
and then there's the bifrost opens up
outside and he knows exactly what that
is oh
oh my god you almost made me cry that's
really [__] sweet
[__] man [__] why don't you work for
marvel [__]
that's good that being because i keep
saying this [__] out loud in a bomb yes
that's the problem i keep saying the
quiet part out
so in every bar across america there's
someone making a better marvel movie
after a few drinks you know what they
should have [__] done
batman
how expensive could that be
um i i did enjoy it you just made me
want to go see it again by saying you
went to see it again and describing some
of it i was like i do want to go see
that again uh taika waititi is hands
down one of the most talented directors
working today i saw a few people on
twitter of course being like
let him never go near a marvel movie
again same things they say about like uh
james gunn uh you know which is to me is
ridiculous james gunn is insanely
[__] talented let him go near
everything let him make clerks three
um
and taika the same thing so like even
though for me like it wasn't ragnarok it
was still a fantastic [__] marvel
movie a great time uh a
a voice
to a marvel film which traditionally in
the past
they didn't really have a sense of an
auteur behind any of them lately we've
been getting more of that you know phase
four seems to be about
letting auteurs bring their voice
to the work as well and you know that's
a voice you hear loud and clear it's
very distinctive you know whose movie
that is
um
so yeah he should keep making [__]
movies forever i think he should keep
making thor movies too those two work
very well together i think they have a
good time like every behind the scenes
thing you see is just a [__] party
rightfully so making movies should be
fun man even that expensive like even if
you're spending 200 million dollars to
make a movie if everyone's not having a
good time doing it [__] like how do
you think it's going to translate in the
real world how is it doing are people
liking it is it making money
uh let's see
3011 thunder
opened domestically to 143 million
dollars
the best showing of the
of the standalone franchise starring
hemsworth is that right yeah that's the
biggest opening of a thor movie ever it
is uh it is however the third best
opening in the pandemic era behind no
way home at 260 million and doctor
strange at 187 million doctor strange is
opening beat thor love and thunder yep
is that right i thought everyone didn't
like gopher doctor strange i mean i
think that it had the the sequel to
spider-man feeling to it where right
where people like this is gonna be the
multiverse oh [__] we're gonna get
answers about spider-man's multiverse
and then like psych yeah
they killed everybody
you know the multiverse is not that but
you said it's the multiverse it's not
that much different what i mean
multiverses are you doing three okay
yeah
doctor strange and the taste of the
multiverse
um so that's still a [__] great
number obviously the biggest number for
a thor picture yeah no it's if it's
trending upwards it's a good thing um
do you think they get to a billion seems
like it worldwide for sure what do you
do overseas i mean it's worldwide it's
never 300 million dollars no it feels
like they'll get there you know it just
got started it's july what else is
coming what could possibly knock it out
i don't even [__] know there's no
fast and furious movie coming so
which would have been the only real
contender what's the next marvel movie
anybody know
black panther
for sure so you're right we probably
will see a [__] trailer
it's a chance
either they'll double down on tv
or they'll give a slip to black panther
what would be after black panther
oh ant-man yeah ant-man quantum mania
and then marvel's
and then i think blade is gearing up
guardians three as well that's right
and the christmas special is that coming
up this christmas yeah he seems very
excited about that she-hulk series is
coming too but i just meant in terms of
the movies yeah
um
so much to look forward to indeed uh so
yeah man you know i know again i've seen
a lot of like [__] what's going on in
phase four
uh i'm not one of those people i'm i'll
continue to watch these movies they have
not lost me by any stretch of the
imagination uh with anything that
they've done in phase four these are my
stories man the way my grandmother would
be like shut up my stories are on
when she was watching the young and the
restless these are my [__] stories
so uh they continue to capture my
imagination it'd be sad if one day i'm
just like nope
i'm just not into this [__] anymore
because right now it's still [__]
everything it's still all the joy of
going to a movie theater that i
experienced in the 80s like like going
to see raiders of lost ark or going to
see [__] empire strikes back when
movies were these big giant things that
like i didn't know how they were made
and i never imagined i'd be somebody who
could make a version of a movie and
stuff so when i watch those marvel
movies in the theater i'm transported
back into a time before i was you know
[__] i'm clever i could do a thing
and then i entered that world man it was
still like a world away
so i love him to death um all right is
that all the reviews that's all the
reviews my friend uh that means we
should head into the news but before
that should we head into the next or no
we do that after the new year before the
q a for the q a all right although
before we do the news yes um
i don't know if you guys remember i was
on seth meyers
which
happened because of a ridiculous
internet campaign
um maybe
and uh
and so there was a there's a guy online
who was like i want to start an internet
campaign to be a guest on fat man beyond
and talk about my comic book that i just
wrote and uh and like everybody tag mark
and kevin into it and see if i can make
it happen and i was like henry i know
who you are you could just [__] ask
me yeah
do all campaign campaign lasts like six
hours because again i know who he is um
and so i know that he bought tickets
tonight so i know he's in the house
[__] hey yeah so i wonder if henry
brass wants to come up and talk for a
little bit emery where are you at come
on up join us up top man
take vamp man's spot
hey man
hey um
it was a very quiet polite
campaign
not obnoxious like mark yeah no no this
is uh an honor thank you so much for
having me welcome to the show my friend
thank you henry and i go way back henry
i met henry when he was a publicist
working for top cow yes um or marketing
executive or whatever that version of
that job
mark silvestri's top cow i got i had the
honor of working with mark in promoting
genius which everyone should check out i
mean it's the most relevant comic of all
time happens every day
there you go buy that
[Music]
and congratulations on your eiser
nomination thank you
[Applause]
there you go
and in comic book speak that's like an
oscar you know that is the other thing
i'm doing in san diego aside from
dodging [__] kovid is going to the
eiseners to probably lose but i will use
gracefully and with greater plum what
night is the are the eyes friday night
so i i will i i will get on twitter post
eisener's one way or another and say
what happened um and hope you win
because i voted for you
oh thank you you can vote if you're a
professional so is that right oh yeah
you can vote kevin because you're just
gonna say am i a professional yeah i
mean
you've written some comments in comics
yeah you've written a comic or two i
have how do i do that how do i how do i
vote twice
for your i mean we could talk about it
after the show it's it's
talk about it now henry
okay absolutely right
um but then henry as many of us do who
hold jobs next to or parallel to the
thing that we want to do was a
burgeoning comic book writer and uh and
has started to do the [__]
professionally um he wrote a beautiful
book about your great uncle my great
grandfather he was a world war ii
veteran and he helped one of the last
native american tribes getting federal
recognition it's called lavoisier mayo
through top cow check it out um
but i'm a huge batman fan so i've been
listening to the show for a long time
and i got to write my first batman story
uh it's a team up with etrigan the demon
oh [__]
yeah um which you were an inspiration
because you got to have those two
characters yeah yeah i got to play with
jason blood and etchkin they're fun
[__] characters and i i did you do
the rhyming etch again i did but i also
um brought back the reincarnators which
is from the original kirby run
and um some of the alan grant stuff and
i bring back his brother uh lord
scapegoat oh [__]
yeah so there is rhyming but there is
not rhyming
and uh randir singh his uh partner he
had in the kirby days i bring him back
to with the help of ram v who is like a
sensitivity reader because we don't want
like what happened with miles or you
know right no you don't want rhyming
thugged out
[__] miles morales thor
they should do that movie someday
because it'd be i mean at this point you
just gotta double down on it right
we made a mistake catastrophic one we
could just back away or
it'll be like zoro the gay blade but for
thor
would that be great
um so yeah man i just i i wanted to give
you a little spotlight i want to give
you a little shine thank you so much she
worked very hard to give me and and my
writing partner adam freeman and
genius as much shine as humanly possible
when's the batman book out uh august 9th
it's in batman urban legends number 18.
and they're like how'd it feel to write
batman well i was writing at the same
time i was writing a marvel avengers
covid comic for the city of new york
and i just felt don't roll past that
it was a marvel
avengers covet comment yeah so gave out
in new york city yeah last year um with
the help of somos healthcare and funnier
die they
gave out
marvel comics of kids before school if
they got the vaccine
and i was playing with a lot of jack
kirby characters so i felt like i got so
much love
and money because of jack
to use etrigan and the avengers
characters so it was a beautiful moment
to do those things simultaneously
and uh you know i mean i grew up reading
your work and like seeing you in wizard
magazine and watching all your movies
so
and reading your batman stuff it was
kind of cool to like think about
literally everything that i had in my
head how can i make this
like feel important or you know do
something that kids are going to look at
and like want to know more about who is
your artist
his name is serge akuna and he's amazing
he did wwe stuff and he's been doing a
lot of dc batman stuff so i got paired
up with someone who who wanted to we
both made each other look good i mean he
made me look even better than i could
ever be but yeah we had
the strengths in each other yeah and
hassan our letter we also also have uh
dave uh
mc
mccraig who was the colorist shout out
to uh
dave and ben and jessica my editors at
dc because uh you know it's a dream come
true it's true no no one person makes a
comic book it is a [__] whole team
like that
um did you just shout out the letter as
well yeah well done
well done
everybody gets their love everybody gets
a piece what was the book at um the
other book called not the dc book um
that the rambling again you say you're
saying it's so fast la vos de mayo
thought the rambo it translates to the
voice of mexican american yakis and
others
that was the organization he co-founded
that helped
thousands
thousands of native americans keep their
homes and keep their land in tucson
arizona and that that was your
grandfather my great grandfather
grandfather yeah how what a [__]
awesome way to honor
a family history and whatnot like while
your great-grandfather is doing that he
was never in a zillion years thinking
one day
yeah there's gonna be a comic book of
this [__]
like how what a wonderful way to honor
the family legacy that's really really
fun thank you it was inspired by march
congressman john lewis did a whole life
story and uh
i was writing the biography and i was
like hey i want to make comics i can
make something like like this not as
good but uh you know i wanted to honor
my family and there's not a lot of
latinx representation in comics
and that was something that was really
important to me shout out to jay gonzo
the artist at bernardo breese who is a
letter and editor uh claire napier and
elena salcedo
uh yeah no it's like you said it's a
it's like a village to make a comic oh
god yeah
excellent man are you going to san diego
i'm a special guest
so oh [__] you're flying me out oh i'm
sorry i thought that was fun
uh yeah flying me out got a hotel so i
will try to check out movies and uh have
a good time
roll on by if you can all right
everybody give up for henry thank you
[Applause]
all right
news
yeah i guess we could go to the news i
wanted to like show the clerk's three
trailer but we always get thrown off
youtube when we show trailers but i
really wanted to test it this time to be
like it's my [__] trailer hey man if
you want to do it i know i don't want to
get locked off and knocked offline we're
having a good time how what's the online
reaction been like tonight jc uh it's
good
people are uh
there aren't very many bad people which
i know i just
opened the internet
well not in our chat room there you go
um i forgot to let people know it was
about to happen normally i put up a
tweet and stuff but
they found it yeah hopefully they'll
find us if they're not watching live
they'll catch up later on
uh but for all those who are watching
after it was live
sorry
i forgot to remind you
i know that's my job
um all right into the news show the news
mark bernard used to be a newshound and
he don't do that [__] no more but like
you could take them the the boy out of
the news but you can't take the news out
of the boy
here is our news boy himself mr mark
bernard a news man if you will give it
up for mark he's got the news
we
did i see
is paper girls a series now yes
where anybody it'll be on amazon it's a
prime amazon yeah prime i was impressed
to see they they did that yeah i had a
friend who worked on it is that right
yeah how close do they state of the
source material um
from all that she could tell me and by
the looks of the trailer incredibly
close
you know like they were doing frame
comparisons and like oh yeah no that's
all right that's spot on that's
and so i'm looking for i don't know very
much about the book i think i only read
the first trade and so i know that it
kept on [__] going
so i'm i'm here for it man i'm a brian k
von stan it's good for him hell yeah he
had that other show right he had
um runaways yeah she's on hulu
did you ever i went to a live reading of
his
round table
it's a script that he wrote
um at this point now like 10 or 15 years
ago there's a spec script that he wrote
which was
if the premise is
london and england is under attack by
like an alien invasion whatever the [__]
and so the only people who rise to
defend the realm
are
famous people who were knighted
and they become the new knights of the
round table so it's like michael kane
and mick jagger
and like it and like like some
philanthropist like richard branson like
all of these dudes who should not be
around to save the world
are the ones forced to say the words
hilarious that's good um and so we had a
lot he had a staged reading god a couple
years ago pre-coveted but i i i will
follow that dude wherever he goes and i
will read whatever he writes and so i
look forward to paper girls but
today the emmy nominations came out oh
[__] yeah did we win
no
[__]
uh and there there was not a ton of
genre love
yeah i mean last last emmys the boys was
nominated for best drama
um they missed the cutoff this year
their their season started too late to
be qualified for the for the emmy so no
love there what about wanda vision was
that last season did they get that was
the last season um and i don't remember
if it was like mini series or whatever
it was drama or i can't remember when i
was categorized
but uh it did not win
any of the big awards it was up for yeah
if i remember correct i should have got
a lot should have got a lot but uh we do
get squid game that did incredibly well
that makes sense um that was wonderful
yeah 14 nominations including best drama
and it's the first non-english drama
ever to do so wow
yeah look at that america is finally
over it's racism we're done
game over you guys
[Laughter]
uh yeah severance and yellow jackets
were among the oh yellowjackets on that
list yeah what would you say right
before yellowjackets uh severance
apple tv adam scott directed by ben
stiller
i was confusing it with uh the
succession yeah yeah yeah
it did very well so several people did
like a lot of people did like that they
did after episode three i was very
confused
i haven't gone back did you finish it i
did not finish it either so and you're
smart so well
i have my moments and that was not one
of them it's uh
under best comedy what we do in the
shadows was nominated
[Music]
my daughter loves that i gotta watch
that you really do and then a bunch of
other [__] that's not genre but but we
happen to like like ted lasso said
laszlo got nominated yep one of the
greatest shows ever made hacks got
nominated yep also a fantastic show
abbott elementary have you watched
happen i watched the first few episodes
that was a good show funny man very only
murders in the building
which i watched the first few episodes
of and i never finished and not because
i was like this sucks i just got busy
but they're on season two now right yeah
they just got picked up for season three
people love that [__] they do and barry
oh [__] barry did he get nominated
for directing um honestly that guy is
one of the best [__] working
directors right now
any get
get out of the way because when he does
a feature there's no way on earth he
doesn't get nominated for directing he's
got such an incredible eye i've been
saying that for like the last two
seasons of watching barry and stuff then
somebody told me they reminded me
that before he went to snl bill hader
was an editor
and now it makes perfect [__] sense
man editors make amazing directors this
guy has such a [__] eye when i watch
the episodes he directs [__] blown
away i've been doing the job 30 years
and i'm like this guy's [__] he
should be doing it more
i'm glad he's got his own show
to like play with and do what he wants
because
once he steps up to features man that's
it he's like a modern day clint eastwood
an actor who could [__] direct but he
sounds like a lot more fun than clint
eastwood
did we ever talk about chippendale
rescue rangers we did a little but it
was wonderful nominated for best tv
movies did it really yeah good for them
man you put in the hard work you deserve
a [__] yeah an award um
one of my favorite nominations um was
chadwick boseman got a posthumous
nomination for his role as t'challa
star-lord in what if oh
that's sweet yeah that's right he was it
was him um oh that's nice marvel got a
nod but we have chadwick i think
anything else i got what if got
nominated for best original animated
show
as it did as did uh rick and morty
as it should arcane did you ever watch
everyone likes that you watch that right
it's beautiful it's beautiful and it and
it gets it starts a little
misty and fudgy and then gets kind of
amazing by the the end of the first
season
um but that's about it man it was not a
big genre heavy emmys
anything
anything in there about masters of the
universe cartoon by the time um
no not not that i saw my friend
interesting yes well
maybe next time
yes
because we missed the cut off
by the power of grace goal we were too
late
uh in other news captain america four
has a director which means that that's a
movie they're absolutely going to make
and that would be that would be anthony
mackie captain america anthony mackie
captain america sam wilson captain
america which is who is just captain
america indeed um a united states
[__]
remember that remember when they [__]
first showed him bust through that
[__] window the shield comes through
the window and he comes in he's wearing
the outfit like a crest white superhero
he did dude this is so [__] shiny
crest new crest
[Laughter]
fighting the cavity creeps and [__] got
the blackest superhero in the whitest
outfit
uh nigerian american filmmaker julius
ohna who directed the 28th thriller the
cloverfield paradox
is direct what was that about
uh that was in space
is that right i think they took
cloverfield to space i believe yeah
i haven't been paying attention
yeah last time they had john goodman in
it that was cloverfield place that was
mary
mary elizabeth winstead yeah i kept on
wanting to go master antonio
but wait so they did another one and
they went to space with it they went to
space with it
sounds like a joke
they're like what are you gonna do with
cloverfield next go to space
and they're like it's a good [__]
idea right there you want to write a
cloverfield oh all right are these still
jj movies are you producing them he's
producing them they're all bad robot
jams and so this guy's stepping in to do
it malcolm spellman who we had on the
show yeah about falcon winter soldier is
co-writing it with another writer on the
show a fellow named dalen munson mussen
i enjoyed uh the falcon and the winter
soldier which seemed to be set up for
what we're heading towards so and also
seems to be like 900 years ago it does
feel like a while
ago um well good for that guy man indeed
um
hey speaking of marvel shows
charlie cox and vincent d'onofrio
are coming back as daredevil and the
kingpin for echo
oh [__] good yeah that's a so is that
how they're going to be introduced or
well i mean i guess technically
they've both been introduced yeah we got
daredevil inspired we didn't get
daredevil yet we got matt murdock matt
murdock and spiderman then we got
kingpin and hawkeye yeah and so now
they're together again for the first
time in this version of the mcu on echo
which is another thing they could show
us some of if they wanted to have they
started shooting that uh i believe they
have yeah
there's also a rumor
that uh that matt murdock is searching
out a former ally in the show and that
ally being jessica jones
so
um it's unclear if that's jessica jones
on a disney plush show
good luck
[Laughter]
um i'd like to see that [__] indeed
um
i went to uh
uh comic-con this weekend as previously
mentioned the chicago fan expo
and um
i've done five or six fan expos now for
years jay has been go i used to go to
comic-cons all the time with jay back in
the day late 90s to the early aughts and
stuff
and then at a certain point like
i stopped going he kept going and stuff
and he also found out all the years that
jay ever went with me to cons like we
did wizard world for [__] a decade
straight all the shows they ever had
never once charged never charged to go
never charged to do anything i was like
he's like i just always told him i was
like look this is how we promote the
[__] we do
so they fly us out there we we do this
and we sign for hours we meet the fans
and [__] like that we'd set up a booth
and sell things i was like but this is
the way it is
i knew there were other people that
charged out there in the world and stuff
but i was like we don't do that so when
i stopped going to the cons jason kept
going to the cons by himself this is
going back years and years ago so he
goes to a con in toronto and he does the
things we normally did to signs for
people takes pictures with them and [__]
like that
at the end of the con they handed him
like ten thousand dollars
and he was like what's this for and
they're like well because you signed and
took all those pictures all weekend long
and he got on the phone with me he's
like we could have been paid
[Laughter]
i was broke
i was like you're also into drugs it's
probably good you didn't have all that
money
[Applause]
so for years he's been going like oh man
these cons are great it would be so good
but if you went with me i said why is it
because i'd make so much more money if
you were there
santa next asylum bomb so i've been
going to the cons with them and
at the cons you see the same [__]
people all the time over and over again
so the people that we see all the time
and we're always near and like they also
stay kind of late and signing and [__]
they've got long lines
is uh all the hobbits they all they all
go unmasked
like to to the shows so elijah and uh it
was dominic and
pippin or whatever the [__] like
all the [__] hobbits billy
i get billy that's his name sean aston i
saw him this weekend and [__] and so
we're always like ships passing in the
night at denver i was heading into the
back and i was [__] just passing like
elijah was sitting at a table signing
with a line in front of him and just as
i walked past him i was like what and he
looked over he's like hey man
and so when i passed him uh this time at
the show
i wasn't even looking i was talking to
somebody else and i guess he was coming
in the opposite direction he got in my
face and goes hey man and i was like
yeah i would
um
i like that they have to be a set
like if you only get three
don't even [__] around no that's
they travel as a group those
[__] are always just headed to
the shire somewhere and [__]
and what's really delightful is like we
all like a lot of us flew home from
chicago fan expo on saturday night so
you know it was like [__]
ron perlman was on the plane
all the hobbits
and [__] silent bob and like i was
last so i saw the hobbits like they were
early in line so they were up front and
[__] you could even though they're short
but you could see them and uh
and so you know they were ahead of me in
line so that all the people that had me
in line behind them
were all like oh my god it's i think
that's the [__] hobbits like you know
like they didn't realize there was a
comic con literally happening six
minutes away so they're like oh my god
it's the [__] i think those are the
hobbits and people are taking out their
phones and [__] like that
then they see [__] ron perlman and
they're like that [__] guy's famous
too and [__] like that
the cameras [__] go to them and [__]
and then i literally in order to
make my [__]
work when i go to a con i bring one bag
but as always happens at a con people
are so nice they bring you things so
like i made this for you i made this for
you i brought you this thing some guy
gave me a gift this time at the con was
so [__] touching he was like he
bought me a bag he goes this is for you
and he had very like and he was a dad
two kids and [__] he had like his eyes
were like very moist and he was getting
emotional
and i said this is for me he got me a
gift he's like well i yes it's just
something that means something to me as
a bag i opened it up and it was an
x-wing that was made of wood and it was
beautiful like it looked like somebody
put it together it would look like a
fancy desk piece in the rich person's
office like oh look at this expensive
looking x-wing
and he goes my father made that for me
when i was a kid because i loved star
wars but we couldn't afford the toys
and i was like let me tell you something
right now this is [__] better than
the toy i had my [__] x-wing broke i
mean literally granted i broke it but
like [__]
you could never break this is a solid
piece of wood i was like please you
should hold on to this he goes no your
work means the world's man i don't know
how to like thank you for what you've
done so i think you should
have this and let me tell you something
like i brought it home so safely tucked
in my bag wrapped it up with shirts and
[__] like that
because
what a gift that's that man's [__]
child that's his gift to the magi
[__] like to have it so deeply
tied in with his with his dad and [__]
like that oh it's incredible it's moving
what happens like the things people tell
you when they come up to you like i've
been trying to meet you for 25 years to
tell you this story and [__] like that
absolutely [__] breathtaking so wait
you took that man's childhood i did
i did
he offered it as tribute and i was like
i do deserve this fair enough
i made a few movies you're right
i tried i tried to be like no but you
can't like in a moment like that like he
put in a gift bag with the cards at me
and stuff like that i didn't want to be
[__] rude and to be honest i wanted
it
i was like this is really nice he
[__] carved like the rockets in the
back i'll bring it in next show
pretty [__] impressive man but like
in such a way where i'm like if my
father could have done this i would have
put him to work
it's really [__] nice so uh the shows
uh have been absolutely [__]
wonderful and stuff but
since people give me [__] at the show
i can't
leave it behind and i don't have a bag
to put under i just have my roll-on bag
so
[__] goes into the bag and other clothes
come out so when we go to these cons me
and jay do pictures as me and jay we do
pictures with the guys from the clerk's
cast i do pictures by myself and then
for a super [__] premium me and jay
put on the outfits and you could take
pictures of jay and sal and bob and [__]
which somebody mocked me for online they
were like oh when does this get sad and
i was like i don't know man i [__]
make pretend with my friend and get paid
for a living there's nothing sad about
that whatsoever
so you know i i in order to make room in
my bag i took out my silent bob coat
and i couldn't just carry it because it
kept falling off my luggage so i put it
on so i'm in line wearing a backwards
baseball cap
and the [__] thing and they're like i
think those are the hobbits i think
that's the guy from beauty and the beast
i know that is [__] silent bob oh my
god he dresses like the character
in disguise
as myself i was wearing like so this
kevin conroy makes these for me man this
was a new one he gave me these these
hoodies i [__] love them and [__] and
i was wearing the one that he made for
the documentary it says clerk on it so
just says clerk
and so i'm walking through the airport
and like uh like one of the united uh
desk people like strides up next to me
as i'm walking and goes like
do you really need to wear that to get
recognized
i get it bro and i told her i was like
look i just have to put my name on all
my shirts so i know they're mine
she was adorable though
um okay where were we
we have uh we have a death in the family
we need to talk about oh [__]
where well
it's somebody i was just reminded of
comic con or not comic-con at fan expo
chicago somebody like somebody here
tonight brought this sweet-ass marvel
book and asked me and mark to sign it
and if i'm gonna hold this up for a sec
just to show up
so
inside are a wealth of
signatures that go across what i'm
assuming is the entire marvel universe
at a glance i see len wine's name you
know for example um and me and mark
added our names and there's way more
[__]
famous people involved in this so
you know uh
this is very uh common
at a uh comic con uh people will like uh
come have me sign a marvel book and i
open it up and it's legends from [__]
wall to wall and [__] this con what i
was overwhelmed with
was the amount of people that brought me
a thing and i would open up and go to
sign and stop dead because i saw stan's
signature
stan's very recognizable signature and
each one you know that's
they're not making any more of those in
this world so they're [__] rare so
when i saw him each time i was like oh
you did it i was like when and everybody
has the story about getting to meet him
before he passed on and [__] and i'm
talking about people have like a captain
america shield he's the center signature
the books the marvel books like that
he's on there these gigantic jam piece
posters he's on there it's really
[__] sweet very overwhelming and when
they include you in a book like this
like whoever whoever's booked this is
they said kevin and mark
uh can both sign thank you to be
included with like [__] legit
heroes like that i was signing so many
jam pieces and this was the sad part so
many of them are gone from this year for
example i signed a thing that neil adams
had just signed like six to eight months
ago i signed a thing that [__] tim
sale had just signed and i was reminded
that tim sale is gone um we lost a lot
of good people in this genre i i don't
want to hear about losing another one
but i guess we should well i mean it's
not an artist except he's 100 an artist
but he wasn't in comics um
and we didn't get it
it's almost a week old this news and we
we haven't gotten to talk about it yet
but
james khan passed away yeah
um and while we all do remember him and
laud him for being in the godfather but
of course we should and you know killer
elite and thief and brian's song he also
made a fair amount of [__] genre
movies including rollerball including
rollerball including including elf
which is 100 of fantasy including misery
including oh yeah alien nation like yeah
that's right he's so good in alien
nation he was that's where mandy
pattagan drank milk to get drunk indeed
spoiled milk wasn't that george
francisco i think yeah george francisco
um but yeah he was an actor who you know
worked for 60 some odd years and never
ever lost a step
and clearly was agnostic as to the
movies he would do other than is this
going to be good could it be good can i
help make it good then i'll do it and
i'll always show up to play hmm
absolute [__] legend yeah man uh
sunny corleone right sunny
santino
santino you gotta get up real quick
college boy what are you gonna do you
gotta get up close about a big you got
to hit him in the head
um he's coming out of the toilet we're
just as thick in his hand is he he's the
he was the guy who made our childhood
rough because that was a man
so if you weren't like that you weren't
a man and stuff that's a [__] man
sonny and the godfather and [__] he'll
beat people up in the street if you ever
watch the clerk's cartoon there's a
short piece like jay and sam bob would
uh come in charles barkley would do
these science lessons and jane soundbob
would come in and be like hey we do the
science section here so dave mandel
who's the co-creator on the show with me
um like kept building them up and then
the final one was charles barkley was
doing thing and then [__] jay and sam
bob show up and they beat the [__] out
of him
and throw a garbage can at him and [__]
like that and it is composed exactly
to how sonny corleone beat up his
sister's husband and the godfather
including biting his hand when he was
holding onto the gate and [__] dave
mandel was especially manic about like
no it has to be beat for beat so when
you watch it it's literally us taking
that [__] scene james khan is is
spiritually responsible for that scene
in the clerk's cartoon that only 18
people ever saw
and they're all here yes
[Laughter]
um well as we say on uh hollywood
babylon that's a big bucket of win that
guy huge bucket of win a cauldron of win
if you will somebody else we lost in the
world we're talking about people and i
found myself
uh profoundly affected by his death
larry storch passed away at age 99.
wow he didn't make he couldn't make it
long enough so [__] close and he was
looking forward to it as well i read it
as somebody was saying like he was
trying to get to 100. larry storch when
i was a kid was one of the most famous
[__] people in the world he played
corporal agarn on f troop um he was in
the original ghostbusters that had the
big gorilla in it and [__] um he was the
voice of drac in the groovy ghoulies the
voice of the joker and i think the
filmation version of the batman cartoons
like batman and robin the one that ted
knight used to be the voiceover guy for
um growing up he was constantly on my tv
he was always on episodes of the love
boat uh he was on a very famous episode
of colombo and [__] like that
he was an absolute like [__] legend
he was on every goddamn game show you
know i grew up watching a lot of tv so
this guy was constantly in my [__]
life
and
he lived to be 99 and when he passed i
was like larry storch was alive all this
time like i had no [__] idea this was
a guy who fired up my imagination my
childhood there's probably a little bit
of corporal agarn in the dna
of like any character i write like
randall or something like that somebody
who's kind of anti-establishmental
um
seeing that he passed away and he didn't
get to 100 i felt like
a little bad for him but 99 is pretty
[__] great it's a decent run but at
the same time i was like there was a
point where he was
like he was as famous as it got
guy was constantly on [__] television
and then
time moved on
tv passed him by
will will here's my question will time
move on for me or if i keep making [__]
until the day i die
will
do i have a chance at still
being relevant when i'm old
i don't want to die alone
i'd much rather die on like a movie set
doing something i love
or die with a bunch of people watching
the movie um one of my movie preferably
um
that they all paid to see um
but like when i hear stories like that
like these tv legends or these legends
of my youth that when i was a kid i was
like it could not be more famous than
that like oh my god this guy is on
almost every [__] chat i knew his
name you know as a child
um i often think about when they pass
you know i'm [__] i'm
my head is so far of my own ass that
when people die i'm like how does this
affect me in the future
but it did it makes me always think
about like is there gonna be a day where
somebody's doing some futuristic version
of a podcast and like remember silent
bob he died 50 years ago today
because i'm going to make it that
[__] long
um i think i want to make sure that i
keep working right up till the end
my kid calls me a workaholic but i don't
think it's that i just think it's like
i've been to the other side like i
worked at convenience stores i worked in
restaurants i had like real jobs and
[__] like that where
it's a job where somebody's like i'm
paying you to do a thing that you
wouldn't do for free because i need
somebody to do it and [__] and thanks to
like this entertainment crap like i've
had a career
that's not been a job like every day
it's a thrill to go to work every
morning i wake up possibilities are
different and changing and [__] like
that so i hope i can keep riding that
out like right till the end i don't want
to like
have those
years where people like oh he used to do
[__] i'd much rather people be like it's
irritating that he still does [__]
you know i whenever i do a thing i
always get [__] blasted by some
people and whatnot i
gave an interview about
like with
forbes.com about a ray of topics and one
of the questions that the interviewer
scott king asked me was about martin
scorsese marvel movies and [__] and i
was like oh [__] i don't want to wade
into this but i was like let me do this
as definitely as eloquently as i can i
gave a very what i felt was deft
eloquent response that condemned neither
and defended both and raised both up and
[__] like that and somebody pulled a
[__] click bait headline that was
just like smith weighs in or [__]
some [__] about like smith defends
marvel and so everybody that [__]
hates marvel like came after film
twitter bro hates my [__] guts
oh my god they hate me so much and so
they all came for me pretty hard the
other day i was at the con so i didn't
realize it was it wasn't until i was
flying home from the chicago fan expo i
was like i'm gonna open up twitter and
see bask in the glow of the clerk's
three trailer that everyone loves so
much i'm like what the [__]
so inhabits get a load of this [__] yeah
i was like can you believe this [__]
um they were sitting a few rows ahead of
me on the plane that's why i did that
but you know i i know [__] a lot of
people hate that i
[__] exist and make things and [__]
but like i i don't know nobody's forcing
anybody to watch it so i don't know why
they'd be upset and number two at the
end of the day it's like
even if you didn't like my [__] if you
don't like me like begrudgingly gotta
admit i've been keeping this [__]
thing going for 30 years
one
one [__]
you know so i i hope to get it keep it
going for another i want to keep it
going till the end robert altman
director great director
uh died on a movie set he went out of
this world toes up in a movie set doing
what he loved also smoked weed every day
i want to be like robert altman i want
to leave this world [__] toes up
going off of a thing i almost did when i
had the [__] massive heart attack it
was after i did a show what a great way
to die that would have been and [__]
[__] doctor saved me
this would have been a good death it
really would have been a good deal so i
don't know man i'm just gonna keep
plugging away i just realized the other
day kilroy uh was here as released today
minted as the first film as an nft that
is my 14th film clerk's three comes out
in september that is my 15th film now i
got a goal now i'm like oh i'm so close
to 20. i just want to make at least five
more movies and if i get to 20 then i'm
gonna try to get to [__] 25. um and
for years you know from now until the
end of time there will be a bunch of
people being like oh each one's worse
than the last [__] this guy
but i think there will always be a bunch
of people like no no i'm gonna give him
one more shot man
i'm gonna [__] pull that lever one
more time [__] lemon lemon lemon [__]
but i'm gonna keep going regardless i
don't want to i don't want to die like
larry storch with people being like oh
he used to do stuff i want to die with
people going like ew he kept doing [__]
till the end
the good news is you can fit lots of
numbers after the word clerks
you ain't kidding man
you ain't [__] kidding i saw some
people because of the martin scorsese
thing some of film twitter came at me
one person was like ew all kevin smith
does his work with the same actors over
and over again and i didn't have the
heart to tell him i stole that from
martin scorsese himself
um they said i was stupid because i keep
making the same movie over and over
somebody pointed this out which i
thought was interesting they did it
critically but i was like huh and i
started thinking about it they were like
this is this guy's fourth movie about
making movies and they're right
like [__] uh zach and mary megaporno
was us telling the story of clerks
essentially jay jane salem bob strike
back which was before that is jane
sambab going to stop a movie from being
made about them jane salam bob reboot is
the exact same [__] plot so they're
doing the same thing there and in clerks
three they make a film so i've made 15
films four of them are about making
movies the first movie i ever made was
about what
what my life was like working in a
[__] convenience store so the fact
that i make movies about people who want
to make movies is not really all that
[__] surprising no like and people
pick genres you know [__] martin
scorsese likes to do gangsters and
[__] some people like to do westerns
and [__] like that my chosen genre is
like outsiders who like to make movies
and and it's not hard to figure out
[__] why so when the person came at
me about that at first i was like hey
and then i was just like
no like they're right i have done it a
bunch but there's a reason like it's
subject matter that appeals to me
because one of the most amazing things
that ever happened to me obviously was
[__] i made a movie and my
circumstances in life completely [__]
changed that is a cinderella [__]
story if i don't make that movie
somebody else makes that [__] movie
but i got [__] personal experience so
it's much easier for me to do it like to
be there before somebody else does it so
yeah
the [__] they come after me for like
it's getting harder and harder to take
seriously the older i get
because like now i see [__] like he has
too much fun
it's like i'm sorry i'll suffer for my
art in the future right
but yeah
it's i regardless man of of the people
out there that say
mean [__] or whatnot there's so many
more people that say meaningful [__]
like my man at the con who gave me his
dad's [__] toy
or the lady who told me that [__]
mall rat stopped her from killing
herself or people that don't tell you
serious stuff i had this girl brie who
built like a
tusk apparatus it was a costume and it
was on like pvc rolling pipes so she
could go inside it and look through the
eyes and [__] it was impressive as [__]
man real big and so i was like oh [__]
i'm going to tweet this up and i tweeted
up a picture of me with it and her guy
she's always with a guy i met him at the
chicago movies she was dressed like
cocknocker he was dressed like bartleby
so in my tweet i was like brie i know
her name i didn't know his name was like
bringing her man cosplay that blah blah
blah and bri [__] told me the next
day she saw me at the con she goes that
man that's my father
oh
and i was like no with all due respect
he's very young looking and she's like
either that or a [__] hag and i was
like not you he's the freak he was very
young looking he looked like a [__]
boy and [__] so i had to put up a
corrective tweet going like not her man
her dad
also a man
then i had to put up another corrective
tweet her dad is a man but dot
yeah man go out doing what you love
that's what i say man go out like robert
altman that guy's my [__] hero i want
to die like robert altman i just want to
die in a movie so i've spoken to join
like what what do we do i'm like
[Music]
let them [__] figure it out man worst
day on the set for everybody except me
except for you it's like what the [__]
happened holy [__] what
did you get do you ever wonder how your
story ends
you're storytellers yeah and we spend a
lot of time building three act
structures and we live in a three-act
structure ourselves
and you know we we spend a lot of time
making [__] to try to forget to distract
us from the fact that one day it all
ends
and we have less time in front of us
than before so
i you know i'm not morbid about it but i
did almost die once so i tend to think
about it i've thought about like [__] i
almost know how it ended and then you
know mercifully it's gone on do you ever
think about how how your story ends um
it's funny i remember when when my wife
and i were having our first kid and the
doctor says well do you want to know the
the sex of the child
and i said no
because life only ever gives you but so
many things that are surprises
um and this is one of the very rare
no matter what
good surprises true and so given that
life is is not an abundance of surprises
like
i like being surprised
like i don't want to try and guess the
ending of my life because then i don't
get to be surprised by it
yeah but what if you're surprised we're
like there's a [__] car coming like
and if you knew in advance you might
have walked a little faster across the
street or something i mean some
surprises are meant to be spoiled marx
i mean forewarned is forearmed i suppose
but like
it it it seems a little bit of a futile
quest to imagine what will happen i mean
the hope is you know do you think it's
calm you think it likes you old and a
bad just
i mean i'd like to hope it's me
surrounded by the people who i love and
who love me
or
fighting a dragon
maybe would be [__] rad that'd be
amazing it was like this guy they
[__] the movie of your life is just
all the [__] and then the third act all
of a sudden you're like
by the power of grace girls
yeah i would i want it to be that i want
it to be just [__] like warm and
comfy and no pain and you know all of
the people i love around me
or at 120 miles an hour in a [__]
barracuda like trying to break the land
speed record or something [__] like that
just [__]
atomizes yeah
and then i don't die but i go back in
time and then i get to meet myself
you know one of my favorite moments
tv history
um
i was a big x-files fan
so much so that we had dogs named mulder
and scully
um god rest their souls they were
wonderful mulder especially that dog was
so [__] clever he wrote three of my
films
um clive bruckman's final repose
remember that episode with the great uh
peter peter boyle peter boyle
um peter boyle's character has this
ability he doesn't want it but he knows
how people are gonna die
and so uh throughout the episode they
have these cute little moments where our
two main characters have a moment to
kind of probe
clive brookman to be like
how do i die
and so uh
mulder asked him he's like how do you
know how i dies i guess
he goes well but i'm not going to tell
you nobody should really know how
they're going to die
and his moment of silence he goes but i
will say that autoerotica asphyxiation
is a terrible way to die
and boulder's like what the [__]
but when he talks to scully
i i can't i can't do the moment exactly
but she says how do i die and he looks
at her and he goes you don't
[__] love that i still get chills
from that moment where he's like you
don't
and they never touched it they never
went beyond it but it was so [__]
profound that captured my imagination
for years i was like
what the [__] happens she just does she
go to space what the [__] like
is the truth out there like [__]
yeah it's a bit like that and i can't
remember the name of the story um but
it's a sandman issue about a guy named
hob gaddling who dream encounters in
like whatever 1433 in some pub
in
in london and the guy is like i choose
to ignore and refute the very idea of
death i shall not die because i've
declared it nobody has ever declared it
before so i'm just not going to die and
so dream is at this bar with his sister
death and they both look at each other
it's like well should we so yeah let's
just see what happens and so then hob
gatling and then the story follows
every hundred years
morpheus shows up at this bar to see
what the [__] is happening with hob
gatling
and finding his ebbs and flows and
successes and tragedies and
and and it's a beautiful story about
just what it's like to be eternal and
what you give up
for what you think is going to be the
great boon of immortality and that
everybody he's ever known or ever will
know is going to die except for him
you know do you remember how the story
ends
um i don't
does he
die i think
i think he does yeah death does finally
come and take him
in the kindly one storyline yeah which
is finally one storyline he's looking at
the grave if somebody knows and so he
then decides to go
wow [__] neil gaiman man like
didn't it make you ashamed to say like
i'm a writer too
oh my god and he's always so nice to me
he must be like you poor poor
fool like
you're not a writer
yeah really how adorable but i see
you're trying your best yeah
i got this one of my favorite pictures
in the world of neil gaiman um because i
got a bunch uh is one i took of them
when we were in uh australia uh not
together but we were there for like uh
australian their comic con event graphic
festival i think it's called which is at
the sydney opera house and um i pointed
like it's over there um i think it is
him and i were out eating and [__] we
were at one of these outdoor places
where like you know [__] birds gather
but it's australia so the birds are like
very colorful and there's a [__]
picture of neil gaiman holding out his
finger and a bird sitting on it and he
just looks like
francis of assisi like just
like you know [__] i can talk with
the animals even like oh
so impressive
um should we talk about limp dicks
we better
i've been waiting all night for this
part of the show yes that means we're
going to head into the q a soon it does
oh kids the q and a's next and you know
that means right before the q a we bring
our second sponsor of the evening we
teased them earlier and mark just teased
him now
it's not going to be hard
to figure out
who it is it's the good folks at blue
chew ladies and gentlemen what is the
url uh the url is
bluechew.com
promo code fatman to receive your first
month free uh and that's also visit
bluetooth
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank them for sponsoring the podcast
but yes first month free 5 shipping if
you go to bluetooth.com to you know
get it up keep it up
they give you a little extra the good
folks at blue chew what copy did they
send this week all right they always got
some clever hold on clever wordplay
please choose one of these intros
guys it's time to bring that summer heat
into the bedroom or
the temperatures aren't the only thing
that's rising this summer
yeah all right i like that one all right
cool that's right this episode is
sponsored by blue chews
guys confidence can take you far in life
it can also help in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to
step up to the plate
that's where blue shoe comes in it's a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost
you can take them any time day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple i would eat the
whole package just being a constant
state of cat-like readiness just
you should go to bluetooth.com for
details and save information so you
maybe don't know don't do that kids uh
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online no visits to doctor's offices no
awkward conversations and no waiting in
line at the pharmacy and if you're a
patriot blue chews tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discrete package
well you got me on the patriotism angle
until then i was like i don't need that
but i'm like i am an american
soldier boy would take some purchase yes
uh so yes uh if you could benefit for
some extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you sign up promo
code fatman at checkout and just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code fatman to
receive your first month free make love
not war kids eat blue chew and [__]
things
i believe that's their tagline
we thank the good folks at blue chew for
sponsoring us uh yet again and we thank
everybody who's been ordering blue chew
that they keep coming back and stuff it
baffles us but we have a
very limp dick audience out there and
but i appreciate you all getting the
care and the help that you need the
problem is that they have to look at us
and they're like there's nothing
exciting here and then they can pop
their bluetooth
what do you got there
oh i see
uh kids we're heading into the q and a
part of the evening which means
prizes that's right you can win some
[__]
thanks to our good friend brett deacon
and the good folks at screen x and 40x
man we're giving away screen x tickets
here you can go see uh thor love and
thunder if you ask a question and uh
you're gonna get two of these bad boys
ain't nothing like watching a screen x
movie man uh except watching a 40x movie
indeed pretty damn impressive that uh
both of them a great way to see the
flick and this is a great way to see
thor love and thunder it's how i saw it
on a screen x screen surrounded by
[__] picture immersed in the
asgardian world if you will indeed and
also we have today courtesy of the good
folks of the la philharmonic and
sounding point la two tickets to go see
back to the future at the hollywood bowl
with a live orchestra out in the among
the stars a classic hollywood los
angeles experience
absolutely something you can only do in
this town this town does uh funky fun
things from time to time and they always
do fun things at the bowl particularly
with older movies and stuff there's a
chance for you to go hang out the
hollywood bowl see back to the future
yet again to see with the live orchestra
and [__] and since you're outside reduce
chances of catching covid from that
crowd indeed
uh who's giving us these tickets uh the
la philharmonic and uh sounding point la
so do these get
these a special prize or whoever
we can we can do it one of two ways we
can just ask four questions
or field four questions or we can give
the uh the back to the future to the
best question of the night
oh as voters so somebody could get
screen x tickets and
indeed
we're incentivizing
it's got the clear code underneath all
right it's gonna it's gonna create a bit
of competition though and it's gonna
create controversy with people being
like you think that's the best question
well we don't have to choose the
audience can choose by a round of
applause which question was best fair
enough all right so we'll ask three
questions we'll do three questions and
then the best of the three everyone who
asks a question win screen x tickets yes
the best of the three questions gonna
win the uh bonus back to the future two
tickets to the hollywood bowl i like the
way you [__] think man we run a game
show with that kind of logic
like a legit game show not one of those
silly ones not one of those silly ones
raw dogging for money spin the wheel now
i would like to watch that [__] game
[__]
um all right at this point of the
evening of course we rely
on the brains of banff man to help us
through everyone welcome banff man back
to the show bam bam
bamf man uh told us the story a couple
weeks ago getting [__] recognized out
in public and [__] as banff man that
always thrills me i uh i was here i mean
i was here last night like doing repairs
and there was a
family that walked in
and i was like out there and i had like
a dirty tank top like i was in like work
mode i was like repairing some of the
spaceship controls outside and uh i'm a
grown-ass man repairing spaceship
control
nerd bar as they're walking in it's like
two kids
and a mom and a dad and the dad goes
my wife comes back out he's
banff man yeah
it's like hi
um
and uh chicago and i had a lot of people
be like i love fat man beyond and my
go-to response is like oh isn't mark
great that's usually the first thing i
say i'm not good with compliments so i
immediately pass them on to other people
so i was like oh is it mark right and
most people are like he is better than
you and i'm like all right you don't
have to [__] say that
but there were two people that were like
i'm there for banff man
and i was like we've created a monster
tiny but mighty yeah he's gonna have his
own spin-off show soon so what camp man
beyond i was this morning jen was like
uh you were there so late last night
what were you like did you get
everything fixed
and i was like no
she's like what did you do and i was
like i don't remember
i was like
i like cut a board and she's like you
were there until 12 30 and all you did
was cut a board
and i was like oh i remember the people
who recognized me were from iowa and
they like flew into lax to come here
because they were a fan of the show and
then they're like well we have to leave
because
we're driving to disney this was our
disney vacation and they dragged their
two young kids here for the first night
and i like sat and i talked with them
for like two and a half hours and that's
what i did with my night
and i was like yeah i didn't get any
work done but it was fun it's tough
having fans isn't it
i was so hoping you'd be like well and
they flew in for disney and whenever
they came here and then they kidnapped
me we all went to disney
like wally world you and me and all of
my fans i thought that was going like
they took me to [__] disney and i
went on that [__] ride again i mean
they're there right now
we should have done a live looking
they're probably riding the millennium
falcon thank god they had kids otherwise
they would have been like bamf man what
about a three-way man
let's gargle those balls batman
um all right banff man gets to pick he's
the one that chooses we uh
first
i was that can i could throw this in
real quick it's a bizarre thought i had
when jim was like where were you all
this time i had this image of you with
this place closed jerking off in every
booth
you're like it's my place i always want
to [__] do this
may the force be with me
one parsec two parsecs
you came in that thing enjoy your meal
here's a thing that looks like a dick
that your father left for you in the
desert
all these younglings dying
this is why we'll never get a star wars
job nope
all right banff man all right stop
jerking off in the booths and pick
somebody uh derek d
derek get up here man everyone give it
up for derek first question of the night
[Applause]
all right derek d the floor is yours
thank you um also like by the way
congrats again on the eisner nomination
and for another hall h panel um
i know you're sad going after the
amazing josie the pussycatcher
it's fantastic
it hits right in the nostalgia for me
i'm just in that age range and the the
soundtrack is amazing like i have the
record for it and i put it on like from
time to time yeah the the 90s movie it
it really hits um
and i know that you're bummed out that
you go after the star wars panel but
it's great for people like me who can
actually get in for your panel because
i'm actually i'm not bummed because
that's the only way i get into the
marvel panel i'm backstage lurking
and when they try to throw me out i'm
like no i'm next i'm next
um and and so my question is is
comic-con related besides getting coved
unless you're like me and you're lucky
enough to have gotten it in the past
month to where i can walk around the
halls and lick the walls and i'll be
fine like what are you what are you
looking forward to most next week going
to comic-con and if you weren't going in
a professional capacity if you were
going as a fan like what would you
cosplay as what is your thing right now
that you would want to put some time
into to create and
wear and be a geek done and done um what
am i most looking forward to the hall h
panel i'm gonna do on saturday night
after marvel showing like the first
uh five minutes of the movie is going to
be dope and whatnot bringing up the cast
hall h panel is always a good time
unless jj steals the whole [__]
audience again
like you did that one year um but uh if
i was not going as a professional if i
was just going to the con and i was
gonna cosplay
what would i do
i mean i want to say blues brothers but
that's not really on brand for the con
man at all although at the con this
weekend i saw three blues brothers wow
and i was a chicago con so it kind of
makes sense and but i was like ooh
there's a good idea were they all
elwoods
no there was definitely a jig and in
fact it was it might have been a blues
brothers 2000 because they had a little
kid dressed up as well
um
jeez who would i cosplay as i always
just
do silent bob but i mean who would i do
if i could choose another character
jay
i don't think i can pull that off uh
from the genre world who i mean you know
honestly like
i think you could have a pretty like
husky body and still pull off darth
vader
um because there's a lot of cape work
there a lot of layers a lot of cape
doing some jobs yeah you can you can
kind of bury in that it'd be hot though
i saw a brilliant [__] cosplay at the
con
if i was talented i would try to pull
this off in chicago there was a guy
cosplaying as magneto but from the
comics so he looked like magneto from
the comics including a bubble head that
you could not see through and he had a
voice
speaker system so like nato mysterio
mysterio sorry did i say magneto stoner
mysterio
uh so he had the bubble helmet and you
could hear him speak through this voice
thing and he had fans built into the
bubble helmet he took the helmet off at
one point to show me and i was like no
it's gonna be like when spider-man takes
his head off and smokes on [__]
hollywood boulevard don't do it
but he took it off and it looked real
[__] cool man and like it's it it was
an outfit that i think i could have
pulled off and since it was one of my
favorite villains i was like oh
uh so maybe maybe after having seen that
guy mysterio
about you
um
comic-con for me is a bit like remember
when you were in high school or college
usually college
and you wouldn't see all of your friends
from high school
the entire year until like thanksgiving
break and you all come back home for
those three or four days
and that's what comic con is for me for
all of the like the comic creators and
the press members and you know the
occasional famous celebrity person but
it's it's nerd thanksgiving for me i'm a
little
hesitant about engaging in that same way
this year only because lots of the
places where i would meet those people
would be
lobby bars of hotels that were like
oceans of just nerds milling about
trying to get a coors light and and the
sea of people is a thing that i'm not
ready to to swim through yet but it is
still the seeing the people i don't get
to see that often um and i do think that
for every person there's a different
version of comic-con and what makes a
successful con versus not successful one
and you just have to for yourself decide
what that is is it i gotta be in hall h
for the [__] black atom battle
maybe is it i really want to go and
watch these two comic creators that i've
loved since i was 12 have an argument
about [__] that's also cool is it i just
want to go to the adult swim activation
off site and do some fun stuff like
there's there's nine different ways to
con and they're all valid and viable
um but that's just mine is the i just
want to see i want to see my friends
again and i haven't seen you home week
for you sold home week um
and i think if i'm gonna cosplay as
anybody
i i i love the idea of like luke cage
gone to seed
you know like if you could do fat thor
then i would happily do fat cage
i was like
they used to hire me for things but it's
been a while
so i mean there's not so much power man
but
you know i don't know less heroes for
hire and more heroes for lunch
yeah
oh you could hide me with a sandwich
jessica left she's you know
daredevil doing the kid
you know so what the [__] i'm gonna sit
here and watch badminton every day of
course i will i got cornholed on espn2
now so i'm gonna just do that for a
while and eat lots of cheetos
it's gonna take cornholing on espn
yeah is that a thing do they do it they
[__] do
people cornhole on espn on the espn that
game that game right yes like this i'd
be interested if espn featured real like
our event tonight people getting [__]
in the ass yes my father-in-law loves
that by the way [__] in the ass
i mean the floor is yours we're not
we're not that close but no the the
cornhole and espn like like watch the
game yeah it's like when there's nothing
on no no baseball no nothing cornhole
espn he'll record it and just come back
like weeks later i can see that it's
like methadone for sports addicts it's
like listen i just gotta get me
something to ride me through until
[__] wimbledon starts like cornhole
sure darts why not highlight if it's a
sport cricket maybe but cornhole on
television is [__] insane but then
why not skee-ball
skee-ball's hard you should pitch that
right now
yeah in a world where corn holes out
there like corn holes taking over the
[__] world what else you got them
like skee-ball everybody's cornholing i
need a new thing
we've been on that side angle shot for a
long [__] time yeah there you
go like nobody needs to see me in
profile that long
uh so that's that's that's my luke great
question great answer you get some
tickets give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
excellent job
thank you
uh what are you doing my schedule in uh
comic con is thursday other than all the
times i'm at the movies pop-up there are
three times where i'm actually going to
the comic-con building uh two on
thursday i'm going to moderate the
masters of the universe 40th anniversary
panel
um
it's going to have a
special guest or two show up how are
they that have to do with the next
season of the show that we're doing ooh
um is it me
yes
uh but it's us talking about the toys
the movie the [__] tv show just 40
years of motu history and then after
that i'm uh moderating a panel with the
great william shatner
for a movie that they've made about his
life so i'll be talking to to uh
bill who's always just [__]
wonderful i mean you want to talk about
a living legend an icon and [__] like 91
years old 91 years old and i'm i've i've
worked with bill a couple times
even lately
he drives his own car
like he's not driven places at 91 he
shows up gets out hi how are you you
know [__] he's just ready to go and
[__]
park it close
he parks he parks it close he's he's
he's in charge man he's a captain of his
own ship so i got that and then on uh
saturday i got my hall h panel so those
are the three times i'll interact with
the building what about you doing any
panels you're just there to collect your
tin i got two panels on thursday i got
one panel about it's called a pitching
hour it's all about pitching in tv and
film and comic books nice it's at 12 30
somewhere in the convention center and
then i have another one at 5 30 about
collaboration about creative
collaboration in the modern era
um and so that should be fun just
talking about like again we don't do any
of this [__] alone and so how working
with other people how to best do that
how to best navigate it and how to be
the best version of a collaborator you
can be go see mark you go see me at
comic con coming up not this weekend
next weekend next week and then i got a
bunch of signings um friday saturday and
sunday at the comixology booth for adora
uh you want mark to sign one of these go
to the comicology booth man lionsgate
has a big booth uh activation as they
call it that they're putting together
for clerks three um
i think like you know they're supposed
to do one of their bigger movies and
stuff but the other bigger movie they
moved or whatever so like it's all yours
so they built quick stop you go take
pictures there and [__] like that
um so i know they're doing that and uh
and also at the movies pop-up we'll be
doing stuff the whole time as well a
following weekend after comic con i go
to raleigh to the galaxy con so if
you're in north carolina i will be there
two days after that con i'm gonna go to
new jersey because that day is august
2nd and that will be my 52nd birthday so
what we're doing is having an event at
the secret stash back east
jay just turned 48 in june
i turn 52 on august 2nd so we're having
a dual birthday signing at the store
called 100 years of jay in silent bomb
tickets are now on sale if you want to
go to that that happens on august 2nd
we're doing photos of the store and then
we're doing a jay and silent bob get old
at night
as part of the program and stuff uh okay
back to the questions
where are we going jc uh
if this is uh this is a guy who comes
here and he types his questions up
which makes it very easy to read
incredibly orderly and a little [__]
kevin spacey and seven scary
who's our typist very specifically kevin
spacey in seventies yes
just that nothing else um either that or
it's tom hanks he's a big typewriter fan
as well i hear he collects them who's
our type uh this is uh pasquale give it
up for pasquale pasqua get up here
outstanding um nice oh is that a kinky
kelly shirt yeah sure is my friend deep
cuts i mean that's a silent bob hat of
course it is um what you got for us my
friend um so [__] i wrote four questions
so let's see which one he picked um
i have aside from those found in the vue
skew universe
what are your top three
favorite made up products found in
movies or on tv that you wish were real
that you can
think of
that you wish were real and that you can
think of a quick copy to advertise it
right now right here on fatman beyond
okay so the idea is a fake product from
a movie that we wish was yeah so like i
wrote some of my examples so like sex
panther from anchorman or soglo from
coming to america big kahuna burger from
pulp fiction fair enough um okay and
leaving off the escu universe stuff
because movies does exist yes um
let me measure it into reality we did it
[__] happened um
what is the oh uh and back to the at the
end of back to the future
mr fusion
the [__] device that allows you to
put [__] a can and some beer and a
[__] banana peel and then [__]
that's all you need for fuel yes that
would be pretty [__] useful
home-based cold fusion absolutely um
machine and then my copy for it would be
uh
let me see mr fusion
um get out of here
you know maybe there'd be a second draft
of that but you're out of time waiting
that's just first take theaters just
spitballing here just feeling out the
room over to you
we're just leaving it there i'm gonna
leave it right there get out of here
uh i think i want i want the uh
and i don't know why i want it did the
infinity stones count
they're not products well they are now
yeah you can buy them at every disney
store i mean the infini cones from thor
shawarma
i want the 6000 xux
from robocop it's the it's the car that
they have in those fake commercials
that uh
i buy that for a dollar dollar do you
want six thousand it's the one the
chiodo brothers did the big dinosaur
stop-motion thing for right um
and uh
and i think you'd also make it that it's
now uh it's now a [__] hybrid car um
so you could say um
gas prices blow
get a 6 000 sucks
nice that's good nice that's a good copy
right there man sure is it better than
go someplace
no mine was get out of here get out of
here
um uh honorable mention of course goes
to the long-awaited hoverboard
from back to the future i think
everybody would like that not me that
looks dangerous
i saw that movie you get covered by
manure sometimes
you have a copy for that do i have copy
for the hoverboard
um
rise above hoverboard
never never ollie anything again
there you go
uh great question give it up for squally
everybody gets two tickets
two tickets to paradise
enjoy thor my friend
whatever you choose to say
i know i almost took the booze with me
um all right jc our third and final
question of the evening all right last
one and that's what these
maul rats want to know about oh the
camera wasn't on me yeah
all rats
uh looking for zach davis zach get your
ass up here where are you at zach here
comes zach zack's the one that gave us
the cards give it up for exactly zach
zach gave us packs
[Applause]
okay what you got zach how's it going
all right so my friend uh over there in
the corner rob
uh
he just got engaged like a week ago holy
[__] congratulations man what is your
favorite marriage related movie and
what's your one tip for marriage
my favorite marriage related movie is
she's having a baby by john hughes
um it's a very simple story
about uh how selfish
creative people can be
and it's something that uh
you know
uh a
topic i [__] wrestle with uh
throughout most of my life because
that's how i think about it it's my life
it's my life and [__] i forget that i
share my life with other people
sometimes and uh sometimes the creative
draw is is so
self-centered that you know you
forget that there are other people to
consider in the equation so that's
always been my achilles heel to some
degree uh when i watch she's having a
baby that's
kind of how it plays out to me it's very
therapeutic filming that way
um
kevin bacon's amazing in it elizabeth
montgomery is fantastic in it uh
alec baldwin young alec baldwin is
[__] great in it uh it's john hughes
love letter to his wife
he wrote this movie like all about her
um and uh it still holds up
so got great soundtrack too i know kate
bush is on everybody's mind lately
because of stranger things but she's got
songs on soundtrack as well uh my best
piece of advice
uh for married people is i mean it's
cheesy but like happy wife happy life um
you know there's no argument worth
winning
with my wife as far as i'm concerned i
put in the good time and [__] like that
the good fight but at the end of the day
like i learned early on i'm like well
you're never going to get divorced like
you don't want to leave this woman so
like any fight that you have just
[__] end it so oftentimes i'm the one
that's just like you know what
that was stupid let's not do this
anymore and stuff like that
uh my kid is always like why do you back
down because i'm like because i like i
like peaceful life man i don't [__] i
don't need strife particularly with like
the only person i get to [__] in this
world man
it's ridiculous to ever fight with that
person
so um i i tend to
uh kind of let her make all the big
decisions and [__] the things that
like you know that i could live with not
being in charge of i remember early on i
wanted to take the kid to church when
she was young because i was went to
church i was raised catholic i don't
know if you know this but i speak
catholic there's a movie dog mall about
it
and um i remember when the kid was born
i was like well i'm going to bring her
to church like i was brought to church
and my wife was like you are not
and i was like why not and she's like
i'm not gonna let her go be part of any
organization won't let her be [__] in
charge she's like they got women priests
there i was like no she's like well she
ain't going to your [__] church
and so you know early on i was like man
[__] that but i was glad that she didn't
make the kid go to church like you know
years later i was like why was i made to
go to church and chill like that oddly
enough now the kid like a month ago is
like
after being raised with no faith
whatsoever she starts talking about
questions of spirituality i was like oh
i [__] knew it
[Laughter]
um so i you know uh i
with we had a daughter it was very easy
to let jennifer lead in that
respect as well you know i i didn't
raise myself my parents raised me but i
knew what it was like to grow up as a
boy i don't know what it would be like
to be a girl or raise a girl so jen ran
point on that as well
um yeah
you know it's
it's
you always got to think about
the other person's life
you know like i the thing i often say is
like
it's
this person's one and only life they get
to do with it what they want i'm not
going to impugn them for how they want
to live because they don't do that to me
like my wife has never been like
everything you do is [__] wrong
except when we're [__] and that's
fine
but like in real life she's never been
like oh my god [__] you know yoga
hosers what's your [__] problem any
adventure i'd want to go on she's like
all right let's go
so i kind of afford her the same freedom
as well like [__] it's your life you
decide what you want to do with it and
uh
you know i'm lucky enough that she
decides to spend as much of it as she
does
uh with me i like her we get along in
life i think you know
we all dream of romance and being swept
off our feet and falling in love and
stuff like that
and that can happen absolutely but you
know in movies it's two hours and then
credits roll and you're like happily
ever after but they never show you how
it has to keep going
after that and stuff like that and i
think this is gonna sound gross or weird
to some people but
i think the most important thing in life
to some people definitely i'm one of
those people and i think my wife seems
to be as well
is he just wants somebody to watch tv
with
he just wants somebody to be there so
you can look over and be like right
these [__] freakouts in public so
[__] weird right
because otherwise you're alone doing
that [__] you know and it's like it's
not healthy to be alone it's okay to be
alone sometimes i spend a lot of time by
myself my wife and i sleep at two
different times so i get up very [__]
early because i like to get a bunch of
[__] done and whatnot and i travel and
do a lot of shows and i generally go by
myself so i spend a lot of time by
myself and it's great because it gives
me time to like write in my head
but it's not good to be alone man and
the older one gets the more clear that
becomes so
having someone to watch tv with is
insanely [__] important and that's
who we usually wind up marrying
marriages i've seen i'm not gonna say
like this is like a chicken soup for the
soul [__] this covers everybody but
all the marriages i know that have
worked out and not ended in divorce all
those [__] watch tv together
so that's my best advice to you watch tv
together
over to you captain
okay so
my favorite movie about marriage was
that it
um i mean i really really really wanted
to say flash gordon
they do kind of get married 100 get
married at the end [__] yeah ming the
merciless
shanghai's
which i probably shouldn't say anymore
um he kidnaps
yeah dude you're gonna get us cancelled
so stop it but yes i won't do that even
though i love that rendition queen's
rendition of the wedding march is
phenomenal
i tried to get it from my wedding and i
was like come on man and she was like no
no no not having it
well it sounds so mournful and regret it
does it's a sinister version of that
song but it's still [__] awesome
um
so instead i'm going to say the princess
bride
which is also a movie about a wedding
very true um but it is about the perils
of either being forced into a marriage
you don't want to be forced into or
having to marry the wrong person
um
and i think that you
ha understanding who that right person
is for you
is what will
to his point
make it so that you can watch tv
together and not have to speak but still
like be on the same page
um
and i also love that movie and it's
[__] hysterical and it's sweet and
it's full of adventure like it's
it is not four weddings in the funeral
which is also amazing and it's also a
bunch of weddings but this one has
rodents of unusual size so i just
realized i bit something from them
recently without thinking about it i got
a device in a thing i wrote where
somebody uses
a phrase that's not i love you to say i
love you
and i just remembered as you were
talking about princess bride as you wish
right i just i thought i was so clever
in the thing that i just did and i was
like no you just ripped off the princess
bride man
why'd you have to bring that [__] up
um yeah that's a great [__] movie and
i don't i don't have advice that's that
much better than kevin's on the the
ongoing
initiative that is marriage
but i will say that on your wedding day
something will go wrong
it's bound to happen and the moment you
will think it will ruin your [__]
wedding
it'll be the thing you laugh about in
years to come so remember when that
[__] thing that person didn't show up
remember when it rained remember when
that you know uncle gary fell on the
cake remember whatever it is
will be the thing you loved about your
wedding that you hated in the moment and
it's just a [__] party and if it goes
great amazing if not whatever don't
stress over it because that is also the
nine months leading up to a wedding is
all right we gotta [__] choose the
flowers we gotta go pick a cake we gotta
go taste all the food we gotta go do
this we gotta choose tuxes we gotta
choose dresses like it is you're
throwing this elaborate [__] gala
for what is ultimately an exchange of
words between two people
on a on a stage
and so don't [__] obsess over it let
your fiance choose everything
you
pick one thing you give a [__] about
and that's probably gonna be the dj
slash band
you choose the music let everything else
go because at the end of the day it
doesn't matter like happy wife happy
bride happy life
so
enjoy yourself don't [__] sweat the
small things never go to bed angry and
be willing to lose every fight because
there's no winning a fight
so true
in marriage there is no winning no just
bless whatever it is you're wrong
whatever it is you did it the sooner you
get to that point the quicker you can
get past it
because you're getting there anyway yeah
so don't fight it just let go just relax
man just lean into it
strong advice you're telling him but
he's the guy getting married i know
you know we got a whole you know looking
eye thing excellent [__] question
take your tickets man well done give it
up for him
the uh
the best
wedding advice i can give
as somebody who's not married is
is do it soon
don't schedule it for april of 2020 or
april of 2021 because it may not happen
yeah just go to [__] town hall here's
my my best wedding advice and it doesn't
come from my wedding because we just
eloped at skywalker ranch humblebrag
um my brother uh married my brother
jerry
not my brother but my brother-in-law
jerry uh years ago the same year dogma
came out in 1994
they didn't wait for the government to
say hey it's legal and they're certainly
not scared that the government's going
to take it away either because they were
married before that and [__] they went
to like a [__] unitarian church and
they're like yeah we'll [__] marry
and [__] so we went to the church at the
wedding and [__] my brother through uh
you know the reception great reception
but like at
the same point in any reception it gets
a little [__] like yeah i get it
they're happy let's [__] go like you
know you've celebrated and [__] it's
just kind of boring it's time to go at
that exact moment
at my brother's wedding
a drag show kicked in
and all of a sudden [__] donna summer
was lip [__] last dance
and everybody all these [__] white
people on the floor
including my mother man my mother and my
father it's a memory i'll take with me
forever man there's a drag show going on
there's [__] a bette midler there's
[__] adonis summer there's diana ross
my mother's a big guy in a ross fan and
[__]
and so it's 1994
uh my parents are both uh still alive my
dad's dead my mom's stole that but uh
they're both still alive at this point
my dad had had a stroke
a few uh strokes so he had the you know
the [__] bob dole like his hand is
just kind of like this or whatever the
[__]
um so he's standing next to my mom
normally he had a [__] cane and [__]
but he was
leaning on my mom by putting his hand on
her back and stuff and my mom was like
just [__] drunk and dancing and [__]
like that dancing with diana ross as she
came to the edge of the stage and [__]
and
you know i was like look at him they're
having a good [__] time i'm standing
right behind him with uh i was going out
with scott moser's sister at that point
so me and kristen are behind them and
kristen nudges me to be like look at
your parents because there's my mom like
dancing my dad's got his hand
on my mom's back let me use your bed so
he's got
his hand on her back like up here and
stuff
totally and she's [__] she's way
looser than that way looser
just sloppy loose i mean
she wasn't trying to hump tie into ross
god damn it
so he's working her back here and stuff
and then [__] i swear to god and i'm
standing there watching the show go on
and [__]
and my father's hand i'm not going to do
it to you but drops down her back don't
tease me with a good job
all the way down his hand goes like this
switches
and then goes down her ass and literally
went in and palmed the [__] man
just did this from behind underneath and
grabbed the mound my father to my mother
in front of me
while a drag show was going on so i was
like what's causing all of
this i would love i mean i never thought
i'd say this but i would love to be in
the room when they [__] tonight
[Music]
what was said and [__] it was one of the
most magical moments of my adult life
watching my old man make a move at age
[__] 65 or whatever
go right for it and [__] and she wasn't
like get off me she was leaning into
that [__] man
bearing down
brought to you by blue
[Applause]
oh
as my autumn strangers love that banff
man man they're like
uh all right we did the heavy lifting of
the three questions now we gotta get to
the [__] um the back to the future
tickets indeed to decide what is the
the best of the three which sounds so
merciless at this point
like if i'm one of those three people
i'm like keep the [__] tickets just
don't [__] put me to the test
i didn't come here to be voted on and
feel rejected i came to this [__]
geek bar to drink and hear some [__] and
[__] now i gotta worry about the
pressure of not being good enough
that's a lot yeah yeah
that's what i'd be thinking um but maybe
these cats are not they're like [__]
i'd like to go
like sounds like somebody who's been to
the hollywood bowl no it's too much for
me yeah i was like oh it's so far from
my house it's a five-minute walk
um as close as we are to the hollywood
bowl oddly enough i never hear it you
would think you'd hear even the
fireworks fourth of july never man those
[__] hills are insulate you really
well from sound anyway that's a crazy
weed
yeah
i can't hear anything
smoked myself into total deafness all
right here we go back to the future
hollywood bowl
two tickets it is in the first week of
august i believe either august 5th or
sixth is when these tickets will be four
um okay should we well do we give it to
the best question or we who've traveled
the furthest or
something more democratic than that i
mean traveling the furthest this time
they won't be here for the show yeah
you're right
what if it's traveled the furthest in
l.a like i came from public into hungary
i'm in that water village
yeah brentwood long beach all right well
long beach is pretty far
yeah my condolences anybody beating long
beach
where
santa clarita that's yeah
we're granted google maps
cucamonga
oh congratulations
now people are just yelling [__]
addresses out
i feel like i'm in a warner brothers car
oklahoma
are you really yeah what is it
flemington oh my god i had relatives
from up there the home of flemington
furs
well they better tear it down it should
stop skinning animals that's horrible
but they were huge when i was a kid all
the women and jurors like ah this is a
flemington fur like oh [__] it came from
new jersey
only the best yes from my mob absolutely
[__] throwing shade man but pretty
accurate
murray i bought this coat from my wife
a happy wife happy life get it a
flemington fur
um all right how are we gonna do this
man i mean okay so we have three
questions we had our comic-cons and what
our comic-con ideal comic-con is like i
feel so uncomfortable about this and
what uh how we would cosplay yes first
question was about comic cons and how we
would cosplay san diego comic-con second
question was pasquale which was about
very memorable
but
what was it again
the products right fake products and
movies that we'd want to bring into the
real world
and what's that
and then the last question was about the
newlyweds so we'll leave it up to the
audience and [__] we'll do it by vote uh
let's hear the applause for question
number one
comic-con
[Applause]
okay
let's hear for question number two
sounds about equal let's hear it for
question number three
they like the sweet stuff give it up to
the married boys over there come get
your tickets kids come on
well done zach
my bit of
marriage advice is take your fiance not
your buddy
yes
excellent [__] point
um well lord that was [__] fun
everybody have a good time kids
[Applause]
we covered all the [__] info and
whatnot uh to you at home thanks for
being here playing along to everybody
here in the bar thanks for making it a
lively night at the scum and villainy
cantina kids if you haven't been to this
coming villainy cantina the [__] are you
waiting for you hear the people from
iowa are coming like crazy man
jerseys in the house yes get back get it
get your asses out here come this coming
villainy cantina man if even if it's not
to see fat man be honest just come here
and grab a drink the only bar you'll
never get in a fist fight in i promise
you
unless it's a fist fight over like star
trek versus star wars that's a phaser
fight yeah really at that point well no
it's a fist fight but the music is
it
yes it's it's a mashup between the
cantina theme and the uh
oh my god man uh there is if you like
this show ladies and gentlemen give it
up for the guy next to me without whom
there is no show mr mark bernard
[Applause]
and that
is fat man beyond for this week i'm
kevin smith i'm mark bernard tune in
next week same fat time same fat
channels podcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss everybody good
night
[Applause]
is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens when jay and
sam bob get old up kevin smith
you